GOOD MORNING.
ONE WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
WEDNESDAY APRIL ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
I THINK WE'VE JUST ENOUGH
MEMBERS TO ESTABLISH QUORUM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CHIU HERE HERE MAIENSCHEIN HERE
MAINTAIN HERE CHAO.
CHAO HERE CHOI.
GLORIA HERE GLORIA HERE WE
MONTH.
WHO WOULD?
WE DO HAVE QUORUM I JUST WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND WELCOME OUR
NEWEST MEMBER TO THE COMMITTEE
OUR NEW VICE CHAIR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN WELCOME.
AND A WITH THAT'S.
ONE WE HEAR FROM THE FIRST
AUTHOR WHO HAS SIGNED UP FOR
TODAY AND THAT IS MISTER BLOOM.
FILE ITEM TO A. B. SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE MISTER BLOOM WELCOME
BACK.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK. I.
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY SEVEN THE REGARDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. AND BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF OF
COURSE FOR. A OF THEIR HARD WORK
ON THIS ACOSTA COMMISSION STAFF
AND OUR SPONSORS HAVE ALL BEEN
HARD AT WORK ON THIS BILL.
AT AS YOU KNOW MAY KNOW A
RECENT TWENTY SIXTEEN COURT CASE
THAT COUNT NOW GARDENS VERSUS
CITY OF LOS ANGELES CASE. HAS
UNDERMINED THE APPLICATION OF
BOTH MELLOW AND DENSITY BONUS
ALONG THE COASTAL ZONE. IN COUNT
NOW A DEVELOPER PROPOSED A SMALL
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT IN THE
VENICE AREA OF LOS ANGELES THAT
INCLUDED AFFORDABLE UNITS AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MELLOW ACT.
AND THE DANCE OF THE BOOK AND
QUALIFY FOR DENSITY BONUS UNDER
STATE LAW.
AND ALTHOUGH THE PROJECT WAS
CONSISTENT WITH BOTH LOCAL
PLANNING AND ZONING AND THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DENIED THE PROJECTS
ON THE BASIS THAT THE INCREASED
DENSITY. MADE THE PROJECT
VISUALLY INCOMPATIBLE WITH THE
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOOD IN
VIOLATION OF THE COASTAL ACT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE APPELLATE
COURT UPHELD THE DENIAL.
FINDING THAT COASTAL ACT
SUPERSEDES DENSITY BONUS LAW.
AND IF NOT CORRECTED THIS
DECISION WILL LIKELY PREVENT
DENSITY BONUS LAW FROM BEING
USED IN THE COASTAL ZONE. AND
UNDERMINE THE PRESERVATION
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING UNDER THE
MELLOW ACT.
AT THE END RESULT WILL BE FEWER
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHIN THE
COASTAL ZONE SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN.
ARE NOT REALLY.
AFFORD AT THIS POINT IN TIME. I
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN
WILL CLARIFY  PROVISION IN
DENSITY BONUS LAW TO ENSURE THAT
A PROJECT. CANNOT BE FOUND
INCONSISTENT WITH THE COASTAL
ACT MERLY BECAUSE IT RECEIVES A
DENSITY INCREASE UNDER STATE
LAW.
WE'VE WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY TO
ADDRESS ALL THE CONCERNS SAID
THAT COASTAL COMMISSION HAVE
WITH THIS BILL.
AND TELL THEY ARE NOW NEUTRAL
I'M A GRATEFUL FOR THAT THANK
YOU AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU JUST TO BE CLEAR BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TWO ITEMS TODAY WE THOUGHT
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE FILE ITEM TO
WHICH IS WHAT I ANNOUNCED. NIGHT
WE'RE ACTUALLY ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN THIS IS AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN.
AND WITH THAT LIKE TO ASK IF YOU
HAVE SUPPORTERS I DO AND MY
APOLOGIES ABOUT ONE OF MY
WITNESSES WAS RUNNING JUST.
TED MORRIS.
CALLED OUT OF COMMITTEE.
.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
TRYING TO CAST ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. PLEASE A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL I'D JUST
BRIEFLY TO ADD TO WHAT THE
AUTHOR SAID. THE COURT CASE.
OTHER MISTER BLOOM MENTIONED
SERVE UPSET THE BALANCE BETWEEN
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW AND THE
COASTAL ACT.
AND AS WE WORK.
AS A STATE TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IT'S
CRITICAL. TO ENSURE THAT. WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAXIMIZE
AFFORDABLEHOUSING PRODUCTION IN.
COASTAL CITIES.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT
DENSELY BONUS ALL REMAINS.
A TOOL IN WHICH A VIABLE TOOL
FOR ACHIEVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE COASTAL ZONE WE THINK.
HAVING WORKED WITH THE COSTA
COMMISSION THAT WE HAVE.
REESTABLISH THE BALANCE BETWEEN
THE TWO AND.
FOR THAT REASON WE WOULD URGE
AYE VOTE AND MISTER CHAIRMAN IF
I MAY JUST ALSO NOTE.
I THOUGHT THE ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL WAS EXCELLENT. AND I WANTED
TO COMMEND YOU OR STAFFER.
REBEKAH ABOUT SKI WHO I THINK
YOU'LL AGREE WITH ME HER
EXPERTISE WILL BE SORELY MISSED
IN THIS COMMITTEE.
BURGER DOT I WOULD ASK WHEN
ABOUT AGREED.
IT'S A GOOD WAY TO TRY TO HUNT
FOR VOTES ON THIS COMMITTEE
YEAH.
ANYA LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTERON LAW AND
POVERTY ALSO SPONSOR THIS BILL I
THINK EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE SAID HAS ALREADY BEEN SAID.
SO I'LL DISCUSS VERY VOTE AS
WELL.
AND ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
RAN AWAY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
ASSISTANCE AND ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATIONS PART.
JENNIFER SPEC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
SEAN DEPICTING WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
PARA BUCKLEY ON BEHALF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPORT.
WE NOW ASK IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHO JONES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROTECTION AT
WORK THIS MORNING WHEN I THINK
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS ARE
WORKING REALLY HARD ON THE
AMENDMENTS I HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOR IT. AND THAT THEY JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
WORKING GOT SICK FURTHER CLARIFY
THE BILL I WITH THE CLOSENESS
BUT CCP AND DOESN'T WANT IS FOR
THERE TO BE ANY SORT OF. A LOOP
HOLES ARE IN THERE TO ALLOW FOR
LUXURY DEVELOPMENT TO GO UNDER
THE GUISE OF AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENT AND NOW WE LOOK FOR
TO WORKING BOUT WITH EVERYBODY
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LISTENERS ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION WE CAN BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
THERE'S A MOTION TO MOVE IS OUR
SECOND.
I WILL SECOND IT. ARM LET ME SAY
A FEW THINGS ON THE THANK.
THE AUTHOR.
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
WITH MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE COSTA COMMISSION
ON AMENDMENTS. I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT ENCOURAGING HOUSING
CREATION DEVELOPMENT ON OUR
COASTAL REGIONS IS OFTEN A.
DELICATE BALANCING ACT BETWEEN
OUR NEED FOR MORE HOUSING AND
THE UNIQUE NATURAL RESOURCES ON
OUR COASTAL AREAS. I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RECENT COURT CASE AND THE
CONFUSION THAT MAY BE CAUSING.
AND I DO THINK AT THIS TIME
THIS BILL IS A BALANCED APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE SO I
HAVE A AND I RECOMMENDATION.
ILUSTRES ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
WELL AS THE AUTHOR OF ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE OKAY OTHERS BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD CALL THE
ROLL FOR NOW.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
INVADER REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
SHOOTS AYE CHIU AYE.
MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAU.
CHOI. GLORIA. GLORIA AYE WE
MONTH.
WOULD.
THE THREE VOTES YOU NEED ONE
MORE TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL OBVIOUSLY HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR. OTHER MEMBERS
TO JOIN ON LET'S GO NOW BACK TO
FILE ITEM TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ALL REMAIN OPTIMISTIC ON
THAT BILL BECAUSE IT'LL BE GOOD
TO GET BACK ON THE WITH IN THE
WIN COLUMN IN THIS COMMITTEE.
I'M GOING TO PRESENT TO AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE NOW.
I AM AND I'LL ALSO BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. ARE
ON ON THIS BILL TO. OUR OUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FROM LAST YEAR
INCLUDING A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
SEVEN OF WHICH I WAS A JOINT
AUTHOR. S. B. THIRTY FIVE IN A
NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS IN THE
HOUSING PACKAGE MEAN VERY
LITTLE.
IF OUR STATE RINA ALLOCATIONS
ARE NOT EQUITABLE AND DATA
DRIVEN.
FAIR AND ACCURATE RINA
ALLOCATIONS THAT ENSURE EVERY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS PLAYING A
PART IN ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS THE MAIN GOAL OF AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE. THE
EXISTING PROCESS TOO OFTEN
IGNORES THAT DATA THAT DATA AND
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PUSH
BACK TO WHAT THEY'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH. RATHER THAN WHAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH OUR ACTIONS
A ACCOMMODATE WITH CHANGES IN
THEIR ZONING.
IN AN EFFORT TO ADD AN
INDEPENDENT VOICE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE ADDS EIGHT EIGHT CD
TO THE RAIN A PROCESS.
THIS ALLOWS THEM TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE DISTRIBUTION
METHODOLOGY IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE LAW BEFORE THE NUMBERS ARE
EVEN RUN SO THAT THE COG CAN
MAKE ANY NEEDED CHANGES WHEN.
THEY DO THEIR ANALYSIS.
THE EXISTING PROCESS PROVIDES A
LOOPHOLE THAT CAN ALLOW POLITICS
TO OVERWRITE PROCESS Y
INCLUDING LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS
FOR A COG TO ADD. ANY OTHER
FACTORS TO THEIR DISTRIBUTION
METHODOLOGY.
THIS BILL NARROWS THAT
DEFINITION AND I IN NO THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY A VERY VAGUE.
TERM MANY OTHER FACTORS SO WE
NARROW THE DEFINITION.
OF WHAT.
CONSISTS OF ANY OTHER FACTORS
SO THAT.
ACOG CAN REQUIRE THAT ALL
FACTORS BECAUSE ACOG WILL
REQUIRE THAT ALL FACTORS BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOALS OF THE
STATUTE.
THIS BILL ALLOWS ORGANIZATIONS
TO CHALLENGE RINA NUMBERS AS
WELL AS SURROUNDING
JURISDICTIONS RIGHT NOW.
ONLY THE JURISDICTION THAT IS
ASSIGNED ARENA NUMBER CAN
CHALLENGE AND AS YOU MIGHT
EXPECT.
THAT RARELY IF EVER HAPPENS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
RING THAT SETS
HOUSING ALLOCATION FLOORS NOT A
CEILING FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
GREEN AS A PLANNING TOOL THAT IS
CRITICAL TO SETTING THE STAGE
FOR HOUSING PRODUCTION.
IF THE PROCESS IS FLAWED THAT WE
DON'T GET HOUSING IN THE PLACES
WHERE IT'S NEEDED MOST AND SOME
CITIES UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT HAVE
TO CONTRIBUTE. TO ADDRESSING
REGIONAL HOUSING UNITS.
WHEN JOB RICH DISTRIBUTIONS
DON'T HAVE TO PLAN FOR HOUSING
IT COMPROMISES ARE ABILITY TO
MAYOR CLAVICLES AS WELL.
THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON GETTING
AN EQUITABLE REDISTRIBUTION
WITHIN REGIONS THAT ENSURES THAT
EVERY JURISDICTION IS DOING ITS
FAIR SHARE. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER RELIGIOUS WANNA
PROVIDE YOU'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS EGGMAN GREAT THANK
YOU. TO YOUR SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ON THE LAWLER ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ONE OF THE SPONSORS.
COMPANIES COUSIN CHRIS IS WELL
DOCUMENTED WE TALK ABOUT IT IN
THIS COMMITTEE QUITE A BIT.
OTHER IT'S A THE CRISIS ARE
COMPLEX AND THERE'S BUT THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT SUPPLY PLAYS A
ROLE WE NEED TO PRODUCE FARMER
HOUSING THAT WE HAVE BEEN AND
PARTICULARLY HOUSING FOR
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WHERE THE CURRENT
SHORTAGE IS ACUTE. ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION UNITS.
RIGHT NOW ACCORDING TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
BUT IN ADDITION TO PAVING THE
WAY FOR MORE PRODUCTION WE ALSO
NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO WHERE
THE HOUSING IS ACTUALLY NEEDED
AND ENSURE THAT THOSE PLACES ARE
PROVIDING AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THAT PRODUCTION TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS WHERE THE RAIN COMES IN.
I WAS ADVISED THAT CITY BY A
WISE CALLING TO AVOID ACRONYMS
BECAUSE EVERYBODY HATES THEM
BUT.
I MANY IS THIS ONE FOR THE SAKE
OF BREVITY AND BECAUSE OF THE
TERM YOU CAN HEAR A LOT THIS
YEAR.
RINA MERELY SERVES SHORTHAND
FOR TWO RELATED THINGS THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT PROCESS AND THE
ALLOCATION PROCESS.
.
THE STATE DOES THE ASSESSMENT
PART EVERY EIGHT YEARS A
DETERMINES HOW MANY HOUSING UNIT
THE REGION NEEDS TO PLAN FOR.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE CALCULATION
HOW MANY HOUSING UNITS ARE YOU
GONNA NEED AT THE END OF THE
EXPLAINING PERIOD MINUS HOW MANY
HOUSING UNITS YOU HAVE NOW
THAT'S GOING TO BE HELPED PLAN
FROM THE REGION.
THAT NUMBER THEN GOES TO THE
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS FOR THE
REGION WHICH HAVE TO ALLOCATE A
SHARE OF THE REGION HOUSING NEED
TO EVERY CITY AND COUNTY IN THE
REGION.
THIS IS THERE IN A PROCESS THAT
THAT ISSUE IN THIS BILL HAVING
IT OUT GETS ALLOCATED WITHIN A
REGION IS CRUCIAL TO SETTING THE
STAGE FOR A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN PREPARING THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE
TO SHOW THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH
SAFE ZONE FOR HOUSING WHERE
THEIR. ENTIRE SHARE THE RITA
COULD BE BUILT.
THE LAW RECOGNIZES THAT CITIES
AND COUNTIES GENERALLY ARE NOT
IN THE BUSINESS OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT BUT THEY DO PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE THROUGH THEIR
ZONING POWERS IN SETTING THE
STAGE FOR DEVELOPMENT TO HAPPEN.
THE LAW PROVIDES NUMEROUS
PROTECTIONS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
IS MISTER BLOOM NOTED BOTH
AFFORDABLE AND MARKET A PROJECTS
THAT ARE PROPOSED UNSAFE THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ZONED FOR
HOUSING THESE PROTECTIONS OR
ENHANCE LAST YEAR THROUGH A
NUMBER OF BILLS AND HOUSING
PACKAGE. ESSENTIALLY OF
DEVELOPER PROPOSES A HOUSING
PROJECT IN A LOCATION WHERE
COMMUNITY HAS PLANNED FOR
HOUSING IT'S VERY VERY HARD FOR
THAT PROJECT TO GET TONIGHT NOW.
.
HOWEVER IT NONE THESE LAWS CAN
COMPEL THE PRODUCTION OF HOUSING
IN PLACES WHERE THERE IS LITTLE
OR NO THE PLANS ON FOR HOUSING
OF A JURISDICTION GET THE LOW
REMAIN NUMBER THAT EFFECTIVELY
MEANS THE JURISDICTION CAN SHUT
THE DOOR FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE NEXT DECADE. EVEN EVEN
IF IT'S AN IDEAL LOCATION FOR
NEW HOUSING. THIS IS WHY IT'S SO
CRITICAL TO GET THE REALLOCATION
RIGHT WHEN IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
ALLOCATED AND A DATA DRIVEN WAY
THAT MEANS A VARIETY OF CRITICAL
STATUTORY GOALS SUCH AS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
REDUCING CLIMATE CHANGE
UNFORTUNATELY REGIONAL POLITICS
OFTEN TAKES OVER RESULTING IN
LOW ALLOCATIONS TO CITIES THAT
COULD AND NEED TO ACCOMMODATE
MORE HOUSING BASED ON A LACK OF
WILL RATHER THAN ACTUAL DATA.
THE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO BURDEN
THE COGS OR CREATE MORE WORK
THIS IS ALREADY A LOT OF WORK
FOR THEM WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
GOAL IS TO TAKE THE POLITICS OUT
ENSURE THAT WERE PLANNING FOR
HOUSING IN THE RIGHT PLACES AND.
THAT COMMUNITIES ARE DOING THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
IT'S A COMPLICATED TOPIC BUT
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND WE
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU BRINING US ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN SAID SO
I'LL JUST URGING AYE VOTE THANK
YOU GREAT LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER SUPPORTERS ARE YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
MOVES STEADY GEORGE WITH MY
PLANE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
TARA BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
AND WE ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION.
HI BILL HIGGINSON THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENTS ARE THE COGS WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RENO
DISTRIBUTION WE APPRECIATE THE
INITIAL AMENDMENT BECAUSE THAT.
HELPED ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
AND I'D LIKE TO JUST KIND OF
RAISE A COUPLE OF LARGER ISSUES
ABOUT WHY WE'VE TAKEN THIS
POSITION.
AND THE FIRST IS RECONCILIATION
THE COGS.
WHEN WE DISTRIBUTE THE RENO
RIGHT NOW.
THE RENO DISTRIBUTION IS
SPECIFICALLY TIED TO THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION TARGET.
AND IT'S ENTIRELY POSSIBLE IN
SOME CASES THE A EQUITY
DISTRIBUTION MAY BE ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE GHG
REDUCTION AND IN SOME CASES IT
MAY NOT.
AND IF THERE'S A SITUATION WHERE
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE AT WITH
THE FACTORS.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRED A A
DISTRIBUTION. THAT IS DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WE NEED TO ACHIEVE THE
MAXIMUM GHG REDUCTION WE NEED
SOME KIND OF RECONCILIATION
BETWEEN THOSE TWO. BECAUSE WE'RE
PRETTY SURE THAT A A RP IS NOT
GOING TO GIVE A REDUCTION BASED
ON THAT BECAUSE WE TELEMEDICINE.
SO THIS LAW.
BECAUSE THE RINA IS TIED TO THE
RESULT TRANSPORTATION PLAN NEEDS
TO THINK ABOUT THAT SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT. THE
SPONSORS OF BEEN SYMPATHETIC TO
THAT IN OUR INITIAL CONVERSATION
SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS.
ANOTHER THING THAT WE HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH IS INTRODUCING NEW
PEOPLE INTO THE APPELLATE
TIMELINE.
IN THIS CASE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS
WHEN WE NEGOTIATED S. B. THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THE JXD LA THE.
TWENTY SIX MONTHS LEADING UP TO
A REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN
ADOPTION.
WAS CAREFULLY TIMELINE IN ANY.
DELAY IN THAT PROCESS
COULD AFFECT OUR ABILITY TO WHO
ADOPTED RTP AND ALL THE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS RELATED
TO THAT ON TIME WITH THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAYS ADMINISTRATION
TIMELINES OR POST.
SO EVEN THOUGH DESERVED TO.
ADDRESSING VERY IMPORTANT
FACTORS.
THERE ARE SOME SIDE EFFECTS TO
THIS BILL THAT NEED TO BE WORKED
OUT SO BEFORE WE CAN REMOVE OUR.
.
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SCENE NON LET'S BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. MISTER GORE.
I THINK WAS CHAIRMAN IT FIGURES
TO BLOOM FOR THIS BILL.
AYE AT AND KNOWLEDGE OF THIS OR
POINT OUT THIS IS THE FIRST
HEARING FOR THIS BILL AND I
KNOW.
IS MENTIONED IN THE LOT HARD
WORK I DON'T THINK WHICH HE
BLAMES AFRAID OF DOING HARD WORK
SO. I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
WOULD MEAN THIS BILL.
IT RESONATE WITH MY EXPERIENCES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND SERVING
ON A COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS AND
EVERYTHING OF THE WITNESSES
MENTIONED WHERE THINGS I
PERSONALLY OBSERVED I MENTIONED
THAT IS TRUE ACROSS THE STATE.
OUR MAGIC AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESSING THIS HUGE DEFICIT
THAT WE HAVE ANY MORE HOUSING WE
HAVE IN THE STATE. I'M SITTING
DATA DRIVEN TARGETS YOU KNOW
THAT ARE THAT ARE LESS POLITICAL
IN MORE ABOUT REALITY ON THE
GROUND. THING MAKES A HECK OF A
LOT OF SENSE I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AYE AND LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS TO JUST THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED WHICH
I DON'T THINK ARE INSURMOUNTABLE
AT ALL. ON BILLION APPRECIATION
TO MISTER BLOOM AND I'M OF THE
BILL.
AS MOTION OF THE BILLS ARE
SECOND OR.
THERE'S A SECOND.
ARM.
BUT I JUST SAY I APPRECIATE YOU
TACKLING THIS AREA THERE'S
LAWLER MAY HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON
THEM.
RIGHT AND I THINK WE'RE LARGELY
AGREEMENT ACTUALLY WITH TELL
BECAUSE THAT THIS.
WHATEVER WE DO ON RENO NEEDS TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S CHICHI
REDUCTION GOALS AND NOT IMPEDE
THEM SO WE THINK THAT THERE IS A
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE TO
WORK TOGETHER WE THINK THAT'S
CRITICAL.
AND WE ALSO AGREE THAT
EXTENDING THE TIMELINE WOULD
HAVE ALL KINDS OF NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES IT WOULD DELAY RTP
THAT WOULD PUT COGS BEEN IN
TROUBLE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND IT WOULD ALSO.
DELAY ADOPTION OF HOUSING ON
INTO THE LOCAL LEVEL WHICH WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SEE AND
SO WE REALLY. ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH FOLKS ON
HOW DO WE SORT OF GETS MORE
CHECKS AND BALANCES IN THIS
PROCESS AND ENSURE THAT.
PEOPLE CAN WEIGH IN AT THE
APPROPRIATE STAGE AS WELL SO
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYTHING GETS
HEALED UP WHEN IT'S SUPPOSED TO
SO MORTARBOARD LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AS.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I THINK MY BACKGROUND IS A
FORMER MAYOR. AND FORMER CHAIR
OF THE WEST SIDE CITY'S COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS EIGHTY FOUR TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU BY CHIU
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE CHAU.
CHOI.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE. WE MON. WOULD.
CITY.
THANK YOU HAVE THREE VOTES YOU
NEED ONE MORE.
WILL BE WAITING FOR THEM THANK
YOU.
LET'S NOT MOVE TO MISTER THURMAN
FOR FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
WELCOME IS DIFFERENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD
MORNING INTO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE ME START BY
SAYING EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND IN THE TRADITION
SET BY. MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
MONICA I SHOULD PROFUSELY THANK
THE STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR EXEMPLARY EXTRAORDINARY
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL
DEPRECIATED.
.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
ESTABLISHES A PROGRAM THAT WILL
HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUILD
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING FOR
TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP DISTRICTS
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL RECRUIT AND
RETAIN QUALIFIED TEACHERS.
THE TEACHER HOUSING SHORT THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE HAS BEEN
WORSENED BY HOUSING CONCERNS IN
HIGH COST AREA. LOW SALARIES NOT
COVER HOUSING COSTS IN RULE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS RECRUITING
TEACHERS HAS PROVEN DIFFICULT.
AND IN BOTH AREAS THE LONG
COMMUTE FACED BY TEACHERS AND
OTHER CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
FORCES MANY TO LEAVE THEIR
POSITIONS.
IN FACT ACCORDING TO THE
LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS REPORT A
SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS.
TEACHER HOUSING MODELS HAVE BEEN
USED IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND SOME URBAN
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEES LIKE
CUPERTINO LOS ANGELES.
BEFORE MANY DISTRICTS BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS NOT AN
OPTION DO THEIR BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS
FURTHER FEDERAL STATE SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING PROGRAMS HAD INCOME
LEVEL REQUIREMENTS THAT OFTEN
EXCLUDE TEACHERS. WELL HOUSING
AS A FIRST STEP FOR MANY NEW
TEACHERS ENTERING A COMMUNITY.
AND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT TEACHERS
BECOMING PART OF SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY LEADS TO BETTER
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STUDENTS
PARENTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THAT IS WHY THIS BILL ULTIMATELY
IS ABOUT QUALITY EDUCATION
THROUGH. AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WITH ME TODAY TO ADD EMPHASIS
IS MATTHEW DUFFY WHO WAS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF WEST CONTRA
COSTA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. A
DOMINANT DUTRA AND LEAH DENMAN
WHO ARE WITH DCG STRATEGIES WERE
WORKING WITH THE DISTRICT ON
THEIR EFFORTS TO BUILD SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE HOUSING. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESSES.
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MATTHEW DUFFY AND SUPER. WEST
CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE SERVE CLOSE TO
THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS WITH
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES.
A LIFELONG EDUCATOR STARTING AS
A TEACHER PRINCIPAL
ADMINISTRATOR AND NOW
SUPERINTENDENT. AND IF I WAS TO
START TODAY I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG I'D BE ABLE TO STAY IN THE
BAY AREA.
DUE TO THE HOUSING COSTS
IN OUR DISTRICT WE LOSE ROUGHLY
ONE FIFTH OF OUR TEACHING FORCE
EACH YEAR AND IN LARGE PART IT'S
DUE TO THE COST OF LIVING. THE
ATTRITION RATES ARE PARTICULARLY
HIGH OUR UNDERSERVED SCHOOLS
WERE DISTRICT THAT'S ONE OF THE
MOST DIVERSE IN THE BAY AREA
SPREAD ACROSS SIX UNIQUE
COMMUNITIES WITH SIXTY NINE
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS
QUALIFYING FOR LOW INCOME.
AND IN CERTAIN AREAS OF OUR
DISTRICT SCHOOLS ARE NINETY FIVE
TO A HUNDRED PERCENT LOW INCOME
SO OUR TEACHER NEED IS ENORMOUS.
ON OUR AND WE HAVE INCREASED
COMPENSATION AND SUPPORT FOR
TEACHERS BUT THAT'S ONLY PART OF
THE EQUATION WE NEED INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS LIKE AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. WE HAVE AVAILABLE
LAND EDUCATORS WILLING TO LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE
BUT OUR EXPERTISE IS EDUCATING
CHILDREN NOT MOVING MULTI
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
WE HAD ONE TEACHER LAST YEAR
COMMUNITY LEAST NOW AND A HALF
ONE WAY FROM SACRAMENTO TO
RICHMOND. AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT WILL HELP US AND WILL HELP
THAT TEACHER LIVE IN HER
COMMUNITY.
OUR DISTRICT IS CONTINUING TO
EXPLORE INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
RETAIN OUR TEACHERS WERE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR CITIES
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR TEACHERS TO LIVE WORK AND
PLAY. IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE BUT AGAIN WE NEED YOUR
HELP NOT ONLY WILL AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT MAKE IT
EASIER FOR US TO EXPLORE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING. BUT IT ALSO OFFERS OUR
TEACHERS A PATHWAY AND
ASSISTANCE TO HOMEOWNERSHIP OUR
TEACHERS NEED THIS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY OUR STUDENTS NEED
OUR TEACHERS
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
BOB DOMINIC USUALLY DCG
STRATEGIES.
SO JUST BRIEFLY I'D LIKE TO
JUST SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT.
MY SIMPLY MEMBER THURMOND FIRST
OF ALL. IT'S A VERY PERSONAL
ISSUE BUT ALL PULSE OF SPEAK
BRIEFLY FIRST ON OUR POLICY IN A
PROFESSIONAL BASIS.
THIS IS LIKE OLD HOME WEEK FOR
ME MY DAD SERVED IN THE ASSEMBLY
SO I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE. AND
WHAT YOU CAN DO TO EFFECTUATE
ODD GOOD POLICY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO MYSELF
SERVED ON TO TERMS ON THE
FREMONT CITY COUNCIL WHERE WE
WERE ABLE TO BRING TESLA TO WAS
A FORMER CLOSE PLANT THE GM.
KNEW ME PLAN TO GET PARK TO SAN
JOSE SO. ON A PROFESSIONAL LEVEL
TWELVE YEARS AGO I STARTED A
FIRM DCG STRATEGIES TO WORK WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON. A
SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE WAYS OF
USING THEIR LAND.
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT AND
AS A SUPERINTENDENT HAS NOTED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE NOT IN THE
BUSINESS OF DEVELOPING. REAL
PROPERTY BUT WHAT THEY HAVE
FOUND IS THAT FROM THE
RECRUITING AND RETENTION
PERSPECTIVE. IT IS LITERALLY
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF THE TEACHER SHORTAGE
TO RETAIN AND RECRUIT AND RETAIN
THE STUDENTS.
AND SO WE WORK WITH THEM AND
WITHOUT THE ABILITY FOR THESE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO NOT FUNDS THAT THEY WILL ASK
THE STATE TO KEEP WITHIN THEIR
DISTRICT BUT LOANS PRE
DEVELOPMENT LOANS. AND THE
ABILITY TO HAVE GAP FINANCING
PLEASE THINK A LOT OUT ALONG THE
LINES OF S. B. EIGHT TYPE
FINANCING. SOMETHING THAT HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO CAN FIND
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THIS
CONSTRUCTION BUT NEED SOME GAP
FINANCING THAT THEY CAN REPAY
OVER TIME. TO THE STATE THROUGH
H. CD. AT ALL JUST CLOSE OUR
PERSONAL LEVEL A SPEAKING ABOUT
MY DAUGHTER WHO'S NOW A TEACHER.
MY WIFE AND I ADOPTED MY
DAUGHTER FROM FOSTER ADOPTIVE
FOUR YEARS OLD AYE SHE HAD A
VERY ROUGH.
A BEGINNING OF HER LIFE AND AS A
RESULT STRUGGLED. THROUGHOUT HER
SCHOOL EXPERIENCE EFFECT WHEN
SHE GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
MY WIFE AND I DID NOT KNOW HOW
SHE WAS EVEN GOING TO SUSTAIN
HERSELF MOVING FORWARD SHE
THOUGHT SHE WAS STUPID.
SHE WASN'T STUPID.
SHE HAD LOST CONFIDENCE BECAUSE
OF FOR ROUGH BACKGROUND.
SHE WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO OUT
AS A PART OF MY A ROLAND CITY
COUNCIL TO GET INVOLVED CITY
YOUR FEAR AND IF YOU KNOW CITY
YEAR IT'S A NATIONAL SERVICE
PROGRAM AND DID THAT FOR TWO
YEARS.
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM SHE WAS
ABLE TO BE MENTORED.
BY PEOPLE THAT. TOLD HER THAT
SHE WAS NOT STUPID THAT IN FACT
SHE WAS SOMEBODY THAT TOO HARD
WORK COULD MAKE CHANGE WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
SHE THEN WENT ON TO A JUNIOR
COLLEGE CAREER TRANSFERRED TO
BERKELEY GODDARD OUT BATCHES TO
BE IN BERKELEY.
MY MY WIFE AND MY KIDS ARE
SPANDEX UP SO SHE DECIDED TO GO
TO CHILE AND SPEND A YEAR ARE
TEACHING SO THAT SHE CAN ARE
LEARNED SPANISH FLUENTLY SHE
CAME BACK TO THE UNITED STATES.
DID TWO MORE YEARS THE NATIONAL
SERVICE WITH TEACH FOR AMERICA.
WHERE SHE ACTUALLY GOT HER ARM
GRADUATE DEGREE? AND IS NOW
WORKING AND AND AND OUR THIRTY
YEARS A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER. ARE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ALL SOUNDS LIKE A
WONDERFUL. BEAUTIFUL INSPIRING
STORY UNTIL YOU REALIZE THE MY
DAUGHTER SPANS FIFTY PERCENT OF
OUR GROSS SALARY ON A FOUR
HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT. STUDIO THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY ON SUSTAINABLE.
SHE JUST SHE HAS A SECOND JOB AS
A FULL TIME JOB INSTRUCTOR SHE
JUST INFORMING LAST WEEK THAT
SHE TOOK A THIRD JOB WORKING AT
PETE'S.
AND I THINK IT'S A IT'S A SOCIAL
COMMENTARY. THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE CHARGED IN ON IT HAVE IDEALS
TO TEACH OUR KIDS.
ARM SIMPLY CAN'T DO IT SHE WILL
ACTUALLY BE MOVING HOME. IN MAY.
NOT BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO OR MY
WIFE AND I WANTED TO EITHER AS
WE'RE HAPPY WITH THE EMPTY NEST.
BUT SHE SIMPLY HOUSE TOO SO IT
IS IT'S JUST SO DISPIRITING TO
SEE SOMEBODY. WHO IS WANTED TO
GIVE HER LIFE TO TEACHING AND
CHANGE LIVES A STUDENTS?
SPECIAL ED TITLE ONE SCHOOLS.
AND TO SEE THAT IDEALIZED VISION
START TO FADE FROM HER EYES AS
SHE REALIZED SHE SIMPLY CANCEL.
POOR SELF FINANCIALLY TO DO THIS
SO I WANT TO THANK PERSONALLY
SOME REMEMBER THURMAN. FOR
TAKING LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA
IS SOMETHING THAT IS DRASTICALLY
NEEDED. AND IS NOT A HUGE FIX
THIS LEGISLATION ADDRESSES IT
AND DOES SO EFFECTIVELY SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND AGAIN
I WANT THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMOND FOR HIS HIS
LEGISLATION.
OTHER WITNESSES.
WE ARE DONE AND ALSO DO SURGERY.
AGREEING OFFICE OF EVERYTHING
FENCE BUT INSIDE BUT JUST TO
KNOW IN TWENTY TWELVE THIRTY
PERCENT OF HOMES FOR SALE ARE
AVAILABLE ON THE AVERAGE TEACHER
SALARY. TWENTY SIXTEEN IT WAS
DOWN TO SEVENTEEN PERCENT THAT'S
NOT INCLUDING PLACES LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO IT'S LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT. SO THIS BILL HELPS
DISTRICTS ACTUALLY BECOME MORE
SELF SUFFICIENT BECAUSE THE PRE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDS GETS THEM
STARTED ON THE PROCESS BECAUSE
AS A BROWN'S MENTION. THEIR
MISSIONS EDUCATION IT'S NOT
DEVELOPMENTS SO THEY NEED TO
JUST FIND OUT WHAT THEIR OPTIONS
ARE AND THE UNIQUE THING ABOUT
YOUR HOUSING ALSO BECAUSE I AM
PLEASED THAT IT MEETS A VARIETY
OF NEEDS. BY CREATING AT AN
APARTMENT SITUATION OR RENTAL
REVENUE ACTUALLY CREATES
UNDERSHIRT REVENUE SO ONCE THE
DISTRICT IS ABLE TO COMES NOT
MORE SELF SUFFICIENT. THEY'RE
ACTUALLY HELPING THEIR EMPLOYEES
BY RECRUITING AND RETAINING YOU
KNOW REDUCING TRAFFIC HELPING
THEIR TEACHERS STAY IN THE
COMMUNITY AND ALSO HELPING THEIR
GAIN ACTUAL FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY SO IT IS A LONG
TERM. SOLUTION ONCE THEY'RE ABLE
TO GET BACK OUT FUNDING AND THEN
THIS ALSO ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE ARE
GETTING PEOPLE INTO RENTALS.
SAVING UP THEY CAN NO LONGER
HAVE TO DROP FIFTY PERCENT OF
THEIR MONTHLY INCOME ON HOUSING
THEY CAN ACTUALLY SAVE UP AND
THEN IT GOT A MATCHING DOWN
PAYMENT SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY
TRANSITION TO PERMANENT MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY.
I'LL PAUSE THERE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER BRIAN HOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS WERE PROP. THIS BILL
AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT IS A
SOUND APPROACH TO ADDRESSING.
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE AND TEACHER
HOUSING CRISIS
AS I AS WE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
THEIR SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE STEP UP.
GOOD MORNING US SYSTEMATIC NOT
WITH WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
HERE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA WE APOLOGIZE
WE WERE ABLE TO GET A LETTER IN
IN TIME BUT WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GIVE THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES.
MOTION WITH THE BILL THERE'S A
SECOND.
I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR OF
BOTH FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
AS WELL AS FOR YOUR DEDICATION
TO TEACHER HOUSING. I KNOW THAT
IT'S PERSONAL FOR YOU AS I KNOW
IT IS FOR MANY OF US.
CERTAINLY THOSE OF US FROM
HIGHER COST CITIES WHO ARE SEEN
SO MANY TEACHERS BEING FORCED
OUT OF THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY TEACH TO HAVE TO COMMUTE.
TO OUR THREE HOURS A DAY TO.
TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO THE
CHILDREN THAT WE WANT THEM TO
RAISE SO A THANK YOU FOR THAT I
DO KNOW IT LAST YEAR'S.
HOUSING PACKAGE THAT WE PASSED
THERE WERE FUNDS THAT COULD BE
ACCESSIBLE FOR THIS SORT OF A
PURPOSE BUT I ALSO THINK THAT.
ARE MOVING FORWARD A A SEPARATE
VEHICLE TO SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON
THIS.
IS WORTHWHILE.
AND WITH THAT I HAVE AND I
RECKON WITH THE AMENDMENTS AYE
LESSER ANY FINAL COMMENTS MISTER
CHOI.
YEAH HOMEOWNER AND THAT.
.
NOW DESPITE THE SOME
RECOMMENDATION AND TO SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS OF.
SPECIAL TREATMENT THE FOR ONE
CLASS OF Y. EMPLOYMENT TO ALL
FOUR OF THOSE SO. I HAVE.
ALWAYS UP.
RESPECT OF AUTO SACRIFICES TO
TEACHER SOME A CA AND SO FORMA
EDUCATOR MYSELF.
AND.
THIS IS SO WONDERFUL WAY OF.
.
HELPING OR A STRUGGLING TEACHERS
AND THEN I THINK THIS.
IS A WONDERFUL WAY TO RECRUIT
GOOD TEACHER SAW IT WE NEED TO.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED OF
EDUCATING NOW FUTURE WORKFORCE
OUT OF OUR.
TO SOCIETY AND TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN WE NEED THE BEST TALENT
FOR TEACHERS.
OUR AND ONE WAY IS SO GOOD PAIN.
BUT THE COULD PAY IS SELF LA IS
NOT THE.
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT OF THEIR
SALARY GOES INTO HOUSING VESA
INTO IT USES JUST JUST A THOUGHT
OUTRAGEOUS OUT AND THE RISING
COST OF TO HOW SERIOUS ARE
TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
AGENDA.
DATA ANYWAY WE CAN EVEN IF WE
MAY HAVE TO SINGLE OUT THAT THIS
CLASS OF OUR.
NO PROFESSION R. I M. OR FOR
THAT THOUGH SO IF HE. IF WE
ASSIST THEM.
ANYWAY WE CAN RECRUIT THEM AND
KEEP THEM.
I THINK THAT THIS IS SO GOOD
INVESTMENT TOUGH FOR OUR FUTURE.
OUR OF OUR SOCIETY AND THE FOR
THE.
FUTURE OF THE. CHILDREN IN THE
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER FOR
COMING UP WITH THIS.
YEAH.
AND WITH THAT LESSER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS
TO THE AUTHOR ANY CLOTHES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR COMMENTS
I GUESS I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT.
THERE'S SUCH INCREDIBLE
EXPERTISE IN THIS COMMITTEE THE
MEMBERS WHO'VE COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND WORK ON HOUSING.
IN THIS IS A CONCEPT THAT IS
VERY VERY COMPLICATED AND AND
AND WHILE THERE ARE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED FOR CITIES SAYS
THE CHAIR NOTED.
AS THE PREVIOUS PRESENTATION
THOUGH IT WITH THE NEED FOR
MAYBE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
UNITS WE KNOW THAT CITIES ARE TO
BE STRUGGLING. TO JUST KEEP UP
WITH THEIR OWN HOUSING
POPULATION NEEDS.
WE WANT TO FIND A WAY TO
COMPLEMENT THAT AND CREATE
PARTNERSHIPS I'M ASKING FOR HELP
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON THIS IS
ASPIRATIONAL ON THAT WHICH
CONTINUE TO GROW. AND I'M ASKING
FOR HELP FROM THE CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
SHARE YOUR EXPERTISE ON HOW WE
CAN MAKE THIS A REALITY THE
STATE. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IDOL.
GREAT THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY.
QUESTION DO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION.
CHIU BY CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHAU.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE GLORIA GLORIA
AYE LEE MON.
THE MONTH I WOULD. WAIT I.
YOUR BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT IN SIGN IN ORDER IS MR
INNES ARIANNA.
WITH FILE ITEM THREE AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLONIES.
FOR SO I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE
AND JUST THINK.
THE CHAIR AND AND THE COMMITTEE
ALSO FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
AND AND OUR OFFICE ON.
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO ASSEMBLE
A WORKING GROUP CONSISTING OF
VARIOUS. BUILDING HOUSING AND
ENGINEERING EXPERTS TO DETERMINE
NEW POST EARTHQUAKE BUILDING
STANDARDS.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ESSENTIAL
FACILITIES LIKE HOSPITALS AND
SCHOOLS CURRENT BUILDING CODE IS
NOT IS ONLY DESIGNED TO PROTECT
AGAINST LOSS OF LIFE IF A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE HITS.
THE CODE SAYS NOTHING ABOUT
WHETHER OR WHEN A BUILDING WILL
BE USABLE AFTER A LARGE SEISMIC
EVENT.
EVEN NEW BUILDINGS ARE EXPECTED
TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT REPAIR COSTS
AND DOWNTIME AFTER A MAJOR
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE.
PEOPLE WOULD BE DISPLACED FROM
THEIR HOMES AND WE WOULD FACE A
SIGNIFICANT DESTRUCTION AND TO
BE JOE ECONOMY.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY STANDARDS SO
THAT A BUILDING'S STRUCTURE
FINISHES AND SYSTEMS WOULD
MAINTAIN THEIR INTEGRITY OR
COULD BE RESTORED TO SUPPORT
BASIC FUNCTIONS OF THE
BUILDINGS.
PRE EARTHQUAKE USE WITHIN A
MAXIMUM EXCESS PARA ACCEPTABLE
TIME.
IT REQUIRES THE CBSC TO CONVENE
A WORKING GROUP TO PROPOSE THE
STANDARDS FOR CONSIDERATION. BY
THE CBSC DURING THEIR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TRAIN YOKOTE ADOPTION
CYCLE.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN ENTER BUILDINGS AND
RESUME NORMAL ACTIVITY SOON
AFTER A LARGE EARTHQUAKE INSTEAD
OF HAVING BUILDINGS CLOSED FOR
MONTHS OR YEARS AT A TIME. I'M
JOINED BY STRUCTURAL ENGINEER
RYAN CURSED THING CHAIR OF THE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS.
SEISMOLOGIST DR LUCY JONES OF
WITH THE DOCTOR LUCY JONES
CENTER FOR SCIENCE AND SOCIETY.
YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSUME IN THIS
AREA AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITIES
PEAK TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC. TO THE SEISMIC SAFETY OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
I'M RANKERS THING I'M A
PRACTICING STRUCTURE ENGINEER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND I AM HERE
TODAY AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE STRUCTURES YEARS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SIAKA AS WE CALL
OURSELVES.
BY THE SEVEN MEN HAS GIVEN YOU A
GREAT INTRODUCTION TO THE BASICS
OF THE BILL'S LOUDEST ONE TAKE A
FEW MINUTES THE HIGHLIGHTS SOME
OF THE.
AT THE KEY POINTS THAT WE FIND
SO IMPORTANT ABOUT IT. AND
HOPEFULLY IS DIESEL ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT STILL HAVE.
S. STRUCTURE ENGINEERS WE
UNDERSTAND THE CODE INTENT OF
LIFE SAFETY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T HAVE THAT SAME
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CODE INTENT
AND SO THIS BUILDUP GOES TO
SPEAK TO SOME OF THOSE AYE
MISCONCEPTIONS.
AT FIRST THE BILL REFERS TO A
FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY STANDARD IS
A NEW IDEA.
THIS FUNCTION RECOVERY STANDARD
DOES NOT MEAN IMMEDIATE
OCCUPANCY NECESSARILY FOR ALL
BUILDINGS.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SIGN EVERY BUILDING TO
BE LIKE A HOSPITAL.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL PRESCRIPTIVE APPROACH
TO THE BUILDING CODE.
IT'S INSTEAD IT CONSIDERS AN
APPROPRIATE PERFORMANCE
OBJECTIVE FOR EVERY BUILDING.
BASED ON ITS SPECIFIC USE IT
OF A DOCUMENT SEE IT'S A
SPECIFIC IMPORTANCE TO BUILD A
OF A COMMUNITY TO RECOVER AFTER
EVENTS.
IT'S NOT JUST
PROTECT LIFE SAFETY IS STILL OUR
COMMUNITY RECOVER IN A
MEANINGFUL TIME FRAME.
THIS WILL LIKELY BE SOME SORT OF
SLIDING SCALE TO GIVE SOME
OPPORTUNITY SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
HAVE DIFFERENT BUILDINGS
DESIGNED FOR DIFFERENT TIME
FRAMES OF RECOVERY.
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT A NEW IDEA. UP
PARTS ARE ALREADY IN THE CODE IS
YOU HEARD WE'VE WE HAVE
HOSPITALS AND OTHER BUILDINGS
ARE DESIGNED FOR IMMEDIATE
OCCUPANCY OR SOME SORT OF
FUNCTION RECOVERY BETTER THAN
JUST THE BASIC BUILDING.
IT'S ALSO BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN STUDIED AND IMPLEMENTED A
DIFFERENT LEVELS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES IN ISRAELI BE
IMPLEMENTED TODAY IF WE WANTED
TO.
SECOND DOESN'T CHANGE THE CODE
THIS BILL DOESN'T ACTUALLY
CHANGE OUR CHO THEY JUST FORCE
WORKING GROUP IT'S VERY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO THIS
TOPIC.
BUT THIS WORKING GROUP WOULD
STUDY THE ISSUE CONSIDER THE
CHANGES OF ANY THAT MIGHT NEED
IT'S THE BUILDING CODE.
THEN MAKE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION AND EACH CD.
AS LONG AS THERE IS CONSENSUS
WAS IN THAT WORKING GROUP.
NOW THESE ENTITIES WITHIN
CONSIDERED THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS APART A
NORMAL CHO PROCESS VERY PUBLIC
OPEN PROCESS. AND AGAINST A VERY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT TOPIC
FOR BUILDING BECAUSE THE
CONSIDERING.
AND FINALLY IF IF
RECOMMENDATIONS ACTUALLY GOT
MADE IN AND IMPLEMENTED IN THE
CODE.
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THIS WILL
ONLY INCREASE CONSTRUCTION COSTS
ON A LIMITED NUMBER BUILDINGS BY
WOMEN'S AMOUNT OF PERCENTAGE
POINTS.
NOT IN THE END IT WILL ACTUALLY
SAVE MONEY IN THE END.
MANY TIMES OVER BY SAVING IN
TERMS OF REDUCING THE LOSSES
INTERVIEW DAMAGE
AND RECOVERY TIME.
THEIR NUMBER PROJECT CASE
STUDIES THAT SUPPORT THESE
CONCLUSIONS WELLS FOR FEDERER.
REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN RECENTLY
PRODUCED.
SEE OCT SUPPORTS THIS BILL AS IT
STARTS AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
ABOUT AMY FOR SOMETHING BETTER
THAN LIFE SAFETY IT'S LOOKING AT
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE. AND
IMPROVING OUR BUILDING CODES.
AS IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
MOVEMENT
WE ENCOURAGE OUR SUPPORT THIS
BILL ON HAPPEN ANSWER ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AFTER DOCTOR JONES
SPEAKS.
DR.
YOU.
I CAN TELL YOU WITH ABSOLUTE
CERTAINTY THAT THERE WILL BE A
BIGGER. ON THE SAN ANDREAS
FAULT.
WE'RE NOT STOPPING PLATE
TECTONICS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU QUINN. BUT WE
CAN DO A QUITE GOOD JOB OF
TELLING YOU WHAT WILL HAPPEN
WHEN THAT INEVITABLE EARTHQUAKE
COMES ALONG.
WE KNOW THAT MOST PEOPLE WILL
LIVE.
WE KNOW THAT OUR NEW WE HAVE
ASKED OUR ENGINEERS.
TO GIVE US LIFE SAFE BUILDINGS
BUILDINGS THAT DON'T KILL US AND
THEY'VE DONE THAT
QUICK THAT'S
I JUST ONE IN FOUR. MODERN
CURRENT CODE BUILDINGS IN THE
BAY AREA WILL NOT BE USABLE
AFTER THE EARTHQUAKE.
AND.
THIS MAY SEEM EXTREME BUT IT IS
WHAT WE STILL SAW IN NEW ZEALAND
CHRISTCHURCH NEW ZEALAND HAS
BUILDINGS LIKE CARS THAT HAVE
BEEN BUILT. UP UNDER THE SAME
CODE THE SAME SORT OF
APPROACHES.
AND THEY HAD THEIR DESIGNED
EARTHQUAKE WHAT THE CODE SAYS
THEY SHOULD BILL TO IN TWENTY
ELEVEN.
THE CODES DID WHAT IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO NOBODY DIED IN A
MODERN BUILDING.
BUT ONCE THE DUST SETTLED THEY
ENDED UP HAVING TO TEAR DOWN
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED BUILDINGS.
AND THEIR CENTRAL BUSINESS
DISTRICT WAS CLOSED FOR FIVE
YEARS.
NOT JUST THE BUILDINGS THAT WERE
BAD THE NEIGHBORS OF BAD
BUILDINGS NOW DON'T GET TO USE
THEIR BUILDINGS SEVENTY PERCENT
OF THE BILL THE BUILDINGS IN THE
CENTRAL BUSINESS DISTRICT WERE
DAMAGED. A HUNDRED PERCENT WERE
CLOSED BECAUSE OF THE RISK FROM
THE BAD BUILDINGS.
WHEN THIS HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA.
HOW DO WE GET OUR ECONOMY GOING
AGAIN?
IF YOU THINK YOU HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS NOW. IMAGINE WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN WHEN ALL OF THAT DANCE
CONSTRUCTION THAT'S BEEN GOING
AND ALL OF THOSE NEW CONDOS IN
HIGH RISES.
DON'T KILL ANYBODY BUT CAN'T BE
USED WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
MAJOR HOUSING CRISIS IF WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TO BUILD AT
THIS LEVEL. THAT SAYS ALL THAT
MATTERS IS LIVING THROUGH IT NOT
WHAT HAPPENS AFTERWARDS.
AND I POINT OUT THAT.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS NOT A
TECHNICAL ISSUE IT'S NOT HOW TO
BUILD A BUILDING. IT'S A POLICY
ISSUE OF WHAT WE WANT IS THE
STANDARD TO BE DO WE WANT
DISPOSABLE BUILDINGS. ARE THEY
WOULD WANT BUILDINGS WE CAN USE
AFTER THE EARTHQUAKE.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
THEIR SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
HI THERE MY NAME'S HIGHLY
TRAINED I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE EARTHQUAKE
ENGINEERING RESEARCH INSTITUTE.
FLORA AND OTHER NONPROFIT
MEMBERSHIP SOCIETY DEDICATED TO
REDUCING EARTHQUAKE RISK ARE
THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS ARE
EXPERTS ON IN THE FIELDS OF
EARTH SCIENCE ENGINEERING AND
POLICY.
WITH FOR MORE THAN SEVENTY
YEARS WE'VE BEEN DRAWN THESE
EXPERTS TOGETHER TO SHARE IDEAS
AND TO ADVANCE EARTHQUAKE
SAFETY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN IT'S AN IMPORTANT
STEP FOR PREPARING CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND COMMUNITIES TO BE
RESILIENT AND TOOK A QUICKLY
FALLING MAJOR EARTHQUAKES IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
LET ME ASK IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SILVIO FOR OUR
IN BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL.
BUT WE'VE BEEN HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS AND
I THINK WE DO BELIEVE THAT ARE
REMAINING CONCERNS CAN BE
RESOLVED.
MOVING FORWARD ON THE FIRST OF
THOSE CONCERNS AND WE REALLY ARE
TALKING ABOUT PROCESS.
UNDER THE FIRST THOSE CONCERNS
IS WHAT WE VIEW AS A RESTRICTING
OF THE WORKING GROUPS WERE ALL
IN AGREEMENT THAT A WORKING
GROUP SHOULD BE DEVELOPED. A IT
SHOULD BE POPULATED WITH THE
BEST AND BRIGHTEST IN THESE
VARIOUS FIELDS AND THEY SHOULD
GET TOGETHER NATION INVESTIGATE
THIS ISSUE. BUT THE BILL MAKES A
DETERMINATION THAT AFTER THAT
WORK IS COMPLETE THE OUTCOME
WILL BE MANDATORY BUILDING
STANDARDS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT AS WE'VE
SEEN THE PAST PRACTICE ON A HOST
OF ISSUES THAT THAT WORKING
GROUP SHOULD HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
USE THEIR EXPERTISE TO DEVELOP
WHAT EVERTHOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
SHOULD BE. AND THEY MIGHT BE
MANDATORY STANDARDS THEY MIGHT
NOT BE THEY MIGHT BE VOLUNTARY
THEY MIGHT BE SOMETHING ELSE AND
WE DON'T THINK. THAT THE BILL
SHOULD JUST MAKE THE PRE
DETERMINATION WHAT THE OUTCOME
IS. THE SECOND ISSUE REVOLVES
AROUND THE AGENCY AND ENSURING
THAT THE AGENCY RETAINS FULL
AUTHORITY OVER THE PROCESS AND
THE PRODUCT.
YOU CAN SEE IN THE BILL THAT
RIGHT NOW THE WORKING GROUP HAS
BEEN GIVEN THE AUTHORITY TO
DIRECT THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION AND THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSING COMMITTEE IN A
DEVELOPMENT TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH STANDARDS.
WE THINK THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED WE
DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW OF.
ANY OTHER WORKING GROUP THAT HAS
BEEN GIVEN THAT KIND OF
AUTHORITY MOST RECENTLY WORKING
ON BOTH RECYCLED WATER AND EVEY
CHARGING.
THE AGENCIES TO GREAT WEIGHT
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
CAME OUT OF THESE EXPERT WORKING
GROUPS AND WE DON'T SEE THAT
THERE BE ANY DIFFERENCE IN THIS
EITHER. BUT THE IN THE DAY IT IS
THOSE AGENCIES THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO PROMULGATE THE STANDARDS AND
THEY HAVE A PROCESS THEY HAVE
TIME AND WE BELIEVE. THAT
RECOMMENDATION SHOULD AND CAN BE
MADE TO THEM AND THEN THEY MOVE
FORWARD FOR THE ULTIMATE
DECISION BUT AGAIN WE BELIEVE
THESE PROCESS TYPE ISSUES CAN BE
RESOLVED WE HOPE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS TO DO
THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER OPPONENTS TO THE
BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SHOT BACK
IN THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND.
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES TO BE I THINK.
GOOD MORNING I MELISSA BARTON
WITH A A CALIFORNIA COUNCIL WE
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE CIA AND
THEIR POSITION.
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS.
MISTER CHOI. IMPAIRED SHARE. OUR
AYE.
GREED DOT.
A AN ARGUMENT THAT BY DE
OPPOSITION INSIDE THE IS SAYS
SO.
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
ARE COMMISSION PROCESS IS A TIME
TESTED AND THE WORKING FINE.
SIZE SAID THERE SO NOTHING IN.
ALL BREAK A ROUTING EIGHT
WORKING GROUP OUT VIA EXECUTIVE
ORDER NONSENSE SO WE ARE ALL
AWARE OF THE EARTHQUAKE THAT
THREAT.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT
DOCUMENT?
FIRST OF ALL IF IF YOU DON'T
START A CONVERSATION THERE WON'T
BE ANY ADVANCEMENT.
SO.
.
AND IN THIS DAY IDEA OF THIS
BILL I MEAN JUST.
BY THE FACT THAT IT'S A WORKING
GROUP.
COMING UP WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
TELLS YOU THAT.
WE'RE NOT MANDATING ANYTHING AS
A BODY. WE'RE NOT FORCING ANYONE
SPECIFIC THING WE'RE JUST
SETTING A GOAL OF HOW DO YOU
MAKE BUILDINGS NOT BE
DISPOSABLE.
BECAUSE THAT COULD CREATE A
SEVERE.
MARKET DISRUPTION.
SO. YOU'RE YOU'RE BASICALLY
WORKING ON PRE EMPTING THAT
SEVERE MARKET DISRUPTION LATER
ON BY A VERY SMALL MARGINAL.
INVESTMENT UP FRONT.
YOU'VE THE BABY DAYS COOLEY I'M
SORRY THE ARGUMENT IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT COME COMMISSION YOUR
YOU CAN WORK WITH THEM AND THEN
THEY CAN.
MEAT THOUGH WHAT YOU U. S.
DESCRIBING RATHER THAN CREATING
NEW POOL.
BUT.
I THINK I MEAN THE BUILDING
CODE.
PROCESS HAS HAS.
GIVEN CALIFORNIA A LOT.
BUT IT IT'S A IT IS LEFT UP
UNTIL NOW WITH THE ENGINEERS THE
DECISION ABOUT WHAT ARE WE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
AND WHAT THIS IS SAYING IS THAT
THERE ARE TWO SEPARATE ISSUES
THERE'S A POLICY ISSUE OF WHAT
TO AS A SOCIETY DO WE WANT. AND
THEN THERE'S A TECHNICAL
DECISION ABOUT HOW DO YOU
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
AND SO THIS IS A PROCESS TO SAY.
THE. PROCESS HAS WORKED TO GIVE
US LIFE SAFETY BUT IT'S TIME TO
LOOK AT SOMETHING MORE THAN
THAT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
THE COUPLE THOUGHTS I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FOR THIS MEASURE.
YOU AND I HAVE WORKED ON A
NUMBER OF EARTHQUAKE SAFETY
MEASURES OVER THE YEARS.
I WAS EARLY CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL IN PART BECAUSE I REPRESENT
A CITY AS YOU DO.
WITH SIGNIFICANT DENSITY AND
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL LOSS OF
LIFE. OF MY CITY LIKE YOURS AND
MANY OTHERS AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE EXPERIENCED
INCREDIBLE DEVASTATION NINETEEN
OH SIX EARTHQUAKE AND FIRE IN
SAN FRANCISCO NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE LOMA PRIETA. AND.
TO DOCTOR JONES IS POINTS AND I
WOULD SAY THIS TO OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM IRVINE. WE KNOW WITH GREAT
CERTAINTY IT'S NOT A MATTER OF
WHETHER AN EARTHQUAKE IS GOING
TO HIT IT'S A MATTER OF WHEN.
SEVENTY TWO PERCENT CHANCE OF
BELIEVE OVER THE NEXT THIRTY
YEARS.
IN MY CITY WHEN I WAS A LOCAL.
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE INITIALLY
LEGISLATIVE A VOLUNTARY SEISMIC
STANDARD FOR SOFT STORY
BUILDINGS. WHICH WAS ALL GREAT
AND FINE EXCEPT NO ONE. REALLY
TOOK ADVANTAGE OR OR.
TOOK REGARD THE FACT THAT WE
HAD THESE VOLUNTARY STANDARDS SO
WE IMPLEMENTED MANDATORY
STANDARDS WITH ENOUGH TIME FOR
ADDRESS ISSUES AND. IT HAS
WORKED WELL SO AM I DO THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AFFORD IN
PARTICULAR WE KNOW IT'S NOT
ABOUT.
IMMEDIATE LIFE SAFETY CONCERNS
BUT HOW WE RECOVER HOW WE ARE
RESILIENT.
AS COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I THINK WE CAN
JUST LOOK TO.
SOME OF THE CITIES AND REGIONS
OF THE STATE THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY RECENT FIRES AND
MUD SLIDES. TO KNOW THAT IF WE
DON'T GET READY FOR THE BIG ONE.
IT'LL COST US BILLIONS UPON
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO WITH THAT
AND I AM SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ONE JUST CLARIFY TO THE AUTHOR
ARE YOU WILLING TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE ASKED FOR.
YES GREAT YES ARE AND WITH
ANALYSTS ANY FINAL COMMENTS IS
THERE A MOTION TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
AND AND A SECOND.
LET ME ASK THE AUTHORITY OF ANY
FINAL COMMENTS.
YOU YOU ACTUALLY I'LL TAKE YOUR
COMMENTS AS THE COURSE BECAUSE
THAT WAS DISTINCTLY FELT WELL
VERY WELL PUT THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD IS GIVEN SOME THINGS
THAT WERE WORKING ON AND A.
HOMELESS CRISIS THAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW IF IF WE THINK
WE'RE IN A CRISIS RIGHT NOW WITH
HOMELESSNESS.
OFFER THE PROTECTIONS NECESSARY
FOR FUTURE BUILDINGS WE'RE GONNA
BE DEVASTATED BY THE
DISPLACEMENT OF HUMAN LIFE.
IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
THANK YOU WITH THAT BUT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AMENDED IN RE
REFER TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU AYE CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN NO
CHAU.
CHOI.
SHOWING NO. GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
LIMA. FREMONT I WOULD.
WOULD I.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU YOU
CALLING SOMEONE CALL TWO ITEMS
TOGETHER AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE TWO AUTHORS OF.
BILL IDEAS ARE QUITE SIMILAR IN
A JOINT PRESENTATION IN THIS IS
SLIGHTLY UNORTHODOX BUT. NOW
FILE ITEM ONE AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY STEINORTH AS WELL AS
FILE ITEM FOR A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE BY MISTER BONTA LET
ME JUST START WITH A COUPLE
COMMENTS.  I WANT TO THANK
BOTH OF THE AUTHORS FOR FOCUSING
ON A NEW IDEA FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP
AROUND HOMEOWNERSHIP SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS.
I KNOW THIS IS A IDEA THAT
MISTER STEINORTH HAS BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
I THINK THIS IS YOUR THIRD
ITERATION OF THIS BILL.
.
AND A VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
FINE TUNING THIS OVER TIME I.
KNOW MR BONTA INTRODUCED HIS
VERSION OF.
HOMEOWNERSHIP SAVINGS ACCOUNT
THIS YEAR APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH EACH
OF YOU SEPARATELY AND.
WITH MY STAFF WAS TRYING TO
WORK ON SOME CONSISTENT
AMENDMENTS ACROSS YOUR TWO BILLS
BUT ALSO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT THE TWO OF YOU WERE. FOUND
EACH OTHER AND HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS AND I UNDERSTAND.
ARE WILLING TO MERGER PROPOSALS.
TODAY SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND. TURN IT
OVER TO YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND ARE
MERGED EFFORT I WON I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEINORTH FOR.
HIS.
FANTASTIC WORK OVER THE YEARS TO
BUILD THIS IDEA OF HOME
OWNERSHIP SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
SOMETHING THAT.
I THINK REALLY HELP
CALIFORNIANS NEED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO
BE WORKING TOGETHER AS JOINT
AUTHORS BEHIND A. B.. NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE I I KNOW THAT WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I WERE HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL OF
THEM THANK YOU FOR THOSE I'LL GO
OVER SOME OF THE KEY ONES IN A
MOMENT. ALSO.
SOME OF THE THOUGH WONDERFUL
WORK OF A SIMILAR STEINORTH
WE'RE GONNA BE INCORPORATING
INTO THAT THE BILLS WE GO FOR
ITS LET ME JUST GO OVER THOSE
REAL QUICKLY THE KEY COMPONENTS
SO WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. HOW MAKE A FEW COMMENTS I
KNOW SOME OF OUR STEINORTH WILL
AS WELL AND THAT WE HAVE?
OUR.
WITNESSES AS WELL SO I'M AMONG
THE MEMBERS THAT WILL BE
INCLUDING. HOW? THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP SAVINGS ACCOUNT
SWALLOW WILL ONLY APPLY TO
TAXPAYERS THAT MAKE UP.
UP TO HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT OF
AVERAGE MEDIAN INCOME.
MEDIAN INCOME TO QUALIFY FOR
THE HSA.
WE'RE GONNA CAP THE AMOUNTS IN
THE ACCOUNTS AT TWENTY PERCENT.
OF THE MEDIAN HOME VALUE IN THE
STATE.
AND WE'RE GONNA REMOVE THAT
COMPONENT CURRENTLY IN AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE INDICATING
THAT CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE HSA
QUALIFY. FOR A TAX DEDUCTION.
SO THESE WERE ESSENTIALLY
OPERATE.
THE WAY FIVE TWENTY NINE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS DO OR ROTH IRA REYES DO
WHERE IT'S POST TAX DOLLARS THAT
GO IN. AND THEN THERE'S A TAX
ADVANTAGE NAM ON THE GROWTH AND
AND THE THE CAN ONLY BE USED
FOR.
.
PURCHASING OF A HOME FOR FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER.
SO WHEN WE THINK THAT THE WITH
THAT PROPOSED THAT WE HAVE.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS ACHIEVE THE DREAM
OF HOMEOWNERSHIP BY ALLOWING
FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS TO SAY FOR
THE DOWN PAYMENT USING THIS
NEWLY CREATED TAX ADVANTAGED
SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
BY NET MANY DEFINITIONS
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE KEY
COMPONENT TO REALIZING THE
MIDDLE CLASS DREAM BUT WITH
SOARING HOME PRICES.
MANY PEOPLE SIMPLY CANNOT REACH
THAT GOAL AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE GIVES HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS A STEP UP. TO HELP
UNLOCK THE DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN A NEW
OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY DIDN'T
HAVE BEFORE. OUT WITHOUT OUR
WELL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE FIRST TIME
WORTH OUT TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
LOSSES AND CLARIFYING QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT THE BILL INCLUDES
WHAT IT DOESN'T INCLUDE JUST HAD
A COUPLE.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WE ASK.
THE TWO OF YOU TO TAKE A SENIOR
ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND THEN.
I KNOW MR STEINER SPILL THERE
WAS A PROVISION THAT ALLOW FOR
INDIVIDUALS OTHER THAN THE
BENEFICIARY TO KICK AND TO THE
HOMEOWNER SAVINGS ACCOUNT I'M
ASSUMING. YOU STILL WANT THAT TO
BE INCLUDED IN THIS BILL TRAVIS
CRACKED OKAY AND THAT'S FINE BY
GREAT PERSPECTIVE GREAT VERY
GOOD MR STEINER THANK YOU
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ALSO
AM VERY HAPPY TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
TODAY IS A JOINT AUTHOR OF
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
THE HOMEOWNERSHIP SAVING
ACCOUNT EQUIPS FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS WITH THE TOOLS TO
OVERCOME EXTREMES THE EXTREME
COSTS OF HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND MAKES HOMEOWNERSHIP REALITY
FOR OUR RESIDENTS
WHEN ACHIEVABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP IS
THE SINGLE MOST POWERFUL TOOL
FOR ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND IT'S A
SINGLE GREATEST INVESTMENT
SOMEONE CAN MAKE IN THEIR
LIFETIME. WITH THIS BILL WE WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR MILLENNIAL TO
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PLANT ROOTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S REAL FINANCIAL EQUITY AND
USE OUR TALENTS TO ADVANCE AND
IMPROVE OUR STATE.
I I'M VERY ENCOURAGED ABOUT THE.
THE MOVEMENT THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE BILL TODAY AND I'M
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE OUTCOME AND
I JUST AGAIN WANT TO JUST
EXPRESS MYGRATITUDE TO THE
CHAIR AND TO THE MEMBERS. AND
ALSO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
FOR WORKING SO DILIGENTLY TO
COME TOGETHER AND PUT THIS BELT.
THANK YOU OTHER A BILL TO YOUR
SUPPORTERS.
THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ON MAKE THIS BRIEF JENNIFER
SPECK ON THE CALIFORNIA BUT WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT
OF BOTH MEASURES HAPPY TO SEE
THE MARRIAGE BETWEEN THE TWO
BILLS WITH THINK THAT IT'S A
FANTASTIC CONCEPT. OF WHAT WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT AS AS WE ALL
KNOW THE COST OF HOUSING IS
PROVING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER THIS OPPORTUNITY WILL
ALLOW PEOPLE TO FIND A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
THANK YOU NEXT
SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ANTHONY GLASS AND THE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH POLICY WITH
THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE. AND
WE'RE HERE SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE TO SUPPORT
CREATING HOMEOWNERSHIP SAVINGS
ACCOUNT FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS.
THE GREEN LINING THE STATEWIDE
POLICY ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND
WE ENVISION A NATION OR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THRIVE.
AND RACE IS NEVER A BARRIER LOTS
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
ON THIS DAY FIFTY YEARS AGO THE
FAIR HOUSING ACT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW WHICH IS EXACTLY ONE WEEK
AFTER THE ASSASSINATION DOT
KING.
DOCTOR KING EXAMPLE I INSPIRED
MILLIONS OF. OF US TO COMBAT
COMBAT RACISM AND REDLINING.
AND THAT LEGACY LIVES ON AS WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR OTHER FOR
AGAINST OTHER FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION.
THAT BAR PEOPLE OF COLOR FROM
HOME HOMEOWNERSHIP ANOTHER
VEHICLES OF ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
HOWEVER TODAY HOMEOWNERSHIP IS
AT ITS ALL TIME LOW.
THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT R.. HAS BEEN
MARKED BY STAGNANT WAGES RISING
COSTS INCREASING BARRIERS TO
HOUSING AND HOMEOWNERSHIP.
NOWHERE IS THIS CRISIS MORE
ACUTE THAN IN OUR STATE. WHERE A
MAJORITY OF RESIDENTS ARE
TENANTS AND NEARLY A THIRD OF
THOSE TEN AND SPEND MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR INCOME? OUGHT TO
PUT A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD. IN
FACT FIFTY NINE PERCENT OF
RENTERS OF COLOR.
PAY MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF THEIR
INCOMES ON RENT.
AND ARE STATE ALSO HAS A THIRD
LOS HMEOWNERSHIP RATE IN THE
COUNTRY ONLY THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
OF BLACK FAMILIES AND FORTY TWO
PERCENT OF LATINO FAMILIES ON A
HOME. COMPETITIVENESS SCENT OF
WHITE FAMILIES.
IN ORDER TO STABILIZE OUR
GROWING OUR ECONOMY. AYE WE NEED
TO ALLEVIATE HOUSING CRISIS.
AND.
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESPONSIBLE HOMEOWNERSHIP IS ONE
WAY TO DO THAT.
UP IN THIS.
AB SNIDELY SEVENTY NINE WILL
HELP QUALIFYING HOUSEHOLDS WHO
ARE ON THE CUSP OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
TAKE THAT CRITICAL STEP.
IN THIS BILL LOT OF VERSIONS OF
THIS BILL HAVE ALREADY PASSED IN
BUT BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
SIX STATES. AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOLLOW SUIT.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN EXPAND OUR
RESPONSIBLE HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
STRUGGLING THAT'S NOT ONLY STATE
TO THRIVE AND BILL THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS.
MORE MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHAD WOULD DISAPPEAR WITH A
CALIFORNIA CREDIT NEARLY ONE
SUPPORT BOTH BILLS REALLY THANK
THE ARE AUTHORS FOR THEIR
BIPARTISAN LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU.
ACTION BEFORE WE PROCEED I JUST
WANNA MAKE SOMETHING CLEAR FROM
THE AUTHORS WE'RE MOVING FOR
MISTER BONTA AS BILL WITH A
MAN'S. THAT ESSENTIALLY TAKE THE
KEY ELEMENTS FOR MR STEINER
SPILL RATS CRACK NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE IT'S A BILL THAT'S
MOVING FORWARD RIGHT SO I JUST
WANNA CLARIFY NO THERE IS A
MOTION TO MOVE FORWARD BOTH
BILLS I'LL ASSUME THAT'S A.
MOTION BEFORE MISTER BONTA AS
BILL WHICH WOULD LEAVE OUR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY EIGHT MISTER
STARTERS BILL THE COMMITTEE.
GREAT THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
GOOD MORNING SAYS A MATTER NOT
WITH WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
HERE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE MORNING ASSISTANCE AND ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AS A
MILLENNIAL MYSELF PAYMENTS FOR.
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DENKER GOT
HELPFULLY CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT
WERE SUPPORTED PRIOR VERSIONS OF
IT PER SHIP MISTER STEINORTH
LEADERSHIP IN THE PAST ON THIS
AND LOOK FOR SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL.
TO THE OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PERCENT ACROSS
THE CONFERENCE TYPES REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE AMENDMENTS IN AND REVIEW
THEM BEFORE DETERMINE WHAT OUR
POSITION IS NOW AND APPRECIATE
YOUR BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO. TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE CERTAINLY
MISTER STEINORTH AS YOU KNOW IN
YEARS PAST.
I'D BECOME FREE TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS A GREAT
MANY OF OUR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN
THE STATE AND IT IS ALWAYS I'M
OFF TO US THAT ARE MOST
IMPORTANT TO PRESERVE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT BEING REDUCE FOR
CRITICAL SERVICES ALTHOUGH.
OBVIOUSLY TAKEN SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO THIS
MASURE TO THAT EFFECT WHICH WE
APPRECIATE IT WILL BE IN TOUCH
WITH THEIR OFFICES THINK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTY
BAUM ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WERE
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL.
I TOO WOULD LOVE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF BOTH OTHERS TOGETHER.
YOU KNOW AS MISS CORBIN STATED
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
PROTECTING STATE LOCAL BUDGETS
HOW WE VIEW TAX POLICY AND THEN
ADD A LAYER OF DOES THIS REALLY
INCENTIVIZE.
THE BEHAVIOR LOOKING FOR
JUSTICE AND OPPORTUNITY GIVE TAX
DOLLARS AWAY AND SO WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT THEM IMMENSE AND
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO MOVE OUR
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MR MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK.
BOTH OSCAR AUTHORS RESPOND
PRETTY PLEASED TO S. FOR THIS
BILL BUT I REALLY WANT TO GIVE
SPECIAL RECOGNITION TO MISTER
STEINORTH WHO HAS. REALLY
PASSIONATE WORK THIS BILL FOR.
THREE YEARS NOW.
IN AND DIED IN IT SHOWS YOUR
YOUR GREAT WORK ON THE SHOWS
UNFORTUNATE YOU'LL BE LEAVING
THE ASSEMBLY. ARE BUT I THINK
YOUR WORK HERE IN A ON THIS
ISSUE IN PARTICULAR WILL LIVE ON
SO I'VE REALLY WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE YOU AND VERY PLEASED
TO HAVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMENTS.
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU SHARE OF SO JUST TO
CLARIFY IN OF OF.
FOR THAT.
THANK YOU FOR COMBINED THESE
BILLS AND REVIEWING THEM LAST
NIGHT IT MAKES ALL SINCE THE
WORLD AND. WE LOVE IT WHEN
COMMONSENSE PREDATES THAT I IN
THIS IN THE SENATE BUILDING.
WITH REGARD TO THE BLENDING OF
THE BILLS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
HAD LAST NIGHT WAS THE THRESHOLD
OF A AM I THINK I HEARD THE YOU
GOING WITH HUNDRED TWENTY. IS
ALRIGHT AND AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT I REALIZE THAT
CAPTURES MORE PEOPLE.
BUT AS DID SOME QUICK MATH YOU
KNOW IN IN MY DISTRICT THAT'S
BASICALLY PEOPLE A FAMILY FOR A
MIX NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. HOMES THERE YOU KNOW MORE
THAN A MILLION DOLLARS I MEAN
THIS THAT THEY DID NEED TO BE
HIRED THE LOWER THRESHOLD
ADEQUATE TROUBLE WITH CYPRESS
HILL THAT.
BEING DONE ON THE WITH REGARD
TO.
THAT FIREFIGHTERS COMMENTS TO
HAVE DATA TO LOOK AT THE ANY
THIS TWO POINT ONE IS WHAT DO WE
COULDN'T WE CONCEIVABLY. PROJECT
FOR PARTICIPATION A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS AND OF COURSE WHAT IS THAT
MEAN FINANCIALLY FOR THE STATE
IS ANNIE CAN DO IS THAT I ADDED
SEEKING THE BACKUP MAYBE THAT'S
NOT THERE YET AND I REALIZE
YOU'RE CREATING SOMETHING SO
MAYBE HARD TO.
TO SAY SPECIFICALLY AT THIS
POINT BUT ANY PROJECTIONS
ANYTHING YOU CAN SHARE IN TERMS
OF NUMBERS BALLPARK FIGURES.
I THINK YEAH I THINK THAT THE
CHAIR I HAD DONE SOME ANALYSIS
ON THIS ISSUE CAN SHARE THAT ARE
ON THE TERMS OF THE COST I'M
CERTAINLY WHEN WINTERS.
.
A TAX ADVANTAGED AYE
INCENTIVIZING FOR FOR SAVING FOR
A HOME THAT WE THINK THAT WILL
CHANGE BEHAVIORAL IT WE DON'T
HAVE A. STUDY WE CAN SHOW YOU
RIGHT NOW BUT I WOULD THINK
COMMON SENSE DICTATES THAT DOM
FOLKS WHO PARTICIPATE DEFLECTED
IT WITH. THE FIVE TWENTY NINE
COLLEGE SAVINGS PLAN BUT. WE CAN
WORK OUT TO BE MORE SPECIFIC YOU
MISTER GLORIA GET THAT BACK TO
YOU ITEMS THE COST I THINK IT'S
IN THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS IT
SOME OF THE PRIOR PROPOSALS
WERE.
IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS OR MORE
SO SO WE'VE REALLY REDUCE THE
AMOUNT A AND THE COST OF THIS
BILL THAT WAS STRATEGIC I'M ON
AND I'M MISTER CHIU MIGHT
CHAIRMAN YOU MIGHT HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL.
AND SO ACCORDING TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THE COST OF
THE BILL IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
WOULD BE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THE PROJECTION IS EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS I WILL GIVE MISTER
STANDARD CREDIT BECAUSE HIS
INITIAL PROPOSALS WERE IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
THIS. THING DOES MAKE IT GO DOWN
A BIT EASIER.
WHAT LEVEL OF THIS IT'S MORE
THAT ANNOUNCES I'M?
AGAIN TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
WHAT WE'RE BUYING INTO NO PUN
INTENDED.
BUT IT THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
SUPPORT AND AND I RECOGNIZE IT'S
EXTREMELY HARD FOR FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO SAY FOR THIS IS CRIED
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE. AND
STOMACH MAKE IT COMMENTS ABOUT
WHAT THIS MEANS IN TERMS OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THE SECURITY
THAT PROVIDES. YAPPING AT SOME
LEVEL THERE SOME TURNOVER AND
PERHAPS SOME OF REASSESSMENT
SEMI GENERATED SOME REVENUE FOR
THE STATE. NONE OF THAT'S A PART
OF THE ANALYSIS OR NOT BUT.
INTERESTED TO LEARN ARE MORE
INCLINED TO SEE THIS BIPARTISAN
COOPERATION OUT FULLY SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. MISTER SHARP IT'S
OKAY.
OF ASSUMING GLORIA OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WHAT WEEK WE CAN'T HELP
BUT OFFICE OF THE PROJECTIONS
THE COST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AMONG GO BACK TO OUR
RESEARCH IN ECONOMICS DEPARTMENT
AND SEE WHAT KIND OF NUMBERS
THEY CAN COME UP WITH FOR THE
ABILITY TO USE OF THE DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE OPPORTUNITY
WITHIN THE SPELL. OF I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE CAN GUARANTEE THAT
PEOPLE WILL DO IT WE CAN FIGURE
OUT THE. THE SORT OF RANGE OF OF
INCOME AND LIKELY HAD THAT COULD
BE USED BUT I THINK THAT'S
HELPFUL MORE DATA IS ALWAYS GOOD
AND TRYING AGAIN BE RESPONSIVE
THE COMMENTS OF THE FIREFIGHTERS
WHICH TYPICALLY YOU KNOW I
WOULD.
TEND TO AGREE WITH YOU KNOW A
SERVER VERSION OF GOVERNMENT
REVENUES.
YOU.
WE PAY FOR ONE WAY THE OTHER
RIGHT.
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE MAY BE
A MODEST SUBSCRIPTION TO THIS
WITH RELATIVELY MODEST OVERALL
COSTS. AND IF THAT'S TRUE THEN
THEN THAT'S HOW HELPFUL FOR
EVERYONE TO KNOW IF SOME
DIFFERENT WE ALSO KNOW THAT FOR
A VOTE RIGHT.
BUT AT FOR TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL WAS DOING THAT
YOU THINK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
UP A FEW COMMENTS RIGHT
PERSPECTIVE AND I SHARE THIS
WITH THE TWO AUTHORS ON THEIR
ORIGINALLY INDIVIDUAL BILLS BUT
I'LL JUST MENTION TO THE
COMMITTEE. ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT I'D HAD ABOUT THIS BILL
WASN'T EXACTLY ABOUT THE
STRUCTURE OF THIS BILL BUT THE
FACT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT. TAX SUBSIDIES
ALREADY TO HOMEOWNERS.
THERE WAS A STUDY LAST MONTH
ARE THAT SHOW THAT HOMEOWNERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVE
SICK
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. MOSTLY
FROM MORTGAGE INTEREST DEDUCTION
AND PROPERTY TAX.
BREAKS WHERE RENTERS RECEIVE
ONE FIFTEENTH THAT SOME OTHER
WORDS RENDERS WHO MAKE UP A
LITTLE ABOUT A LITTLE LESS THAN
HALF THE STATE.
RECEIVE LITERALLY.
BUT TO HER FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR MULTIPLY THAT BY
FIFTEEN THAT'S WHAT HOMEOWNERS
RECEIVE SO FOR ME. IN THE
CONTEXT OF THAT DISCUSSION AN
ADDITIONAL.
SET OF OF TAX SUBSIDIES I
CERTAINLY LOOK ON WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT SCRUTINY IF A REP TO
ME. BUT I THINK THAT WHAT MR
STEINORTH AND WHAT MR BONTA ARE
PROPOSING ARE MUCH BETTER
TAILORED. TOWARD.
THE NEEDS OF FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS AND I WOULD IF IT WERE UP
TO ME I WOULD LOVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO SHIFT.
THE TAX SUBSIDY FROM WHAT IS A
HIGHLY REGRESSIVE MORTGAGE
INTEREST DEDUCTION AND FOR THAT
MATTER I THINK PROPERTY TAX.
A EXCLUSIONS AS WELL AND SHIFTED
TO TO THIS BUT.
GIVEN THAT.
THE AUTHORS HAVE PARED DOWN THE
TAX IMPACT OF THIS BILL.
I THINK IT IS WORTHY OF OUR
SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION.
I ALSO WANNA RESPOND MISTER
GLORIA AROUND THE THRESHOLD
INITIALLY OUR STAFF HAD
SUGGESTED AN EIGHTY PERCENT AND
MY THRESHOLD.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE CONSISTENT
ACROSS TO REFER PROPOSALS BUT I
THINK GIVEN THAT WE'VE MERGED
INTO ONE THAT IS LESS EXPENSIVE.
I DO AGREE THAT ARE REYES AND
IT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT I
AM I WILL HELP US CAPTURE MORE
FOLKS THAT ARE CHALLENGING
OWNING A HOME SO WITHOUT. A A A
A APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S
DONE.
BY THE MEMBERS AND.
.
I THINK WE'VE HAD A MOTION TO
MOVE FOR MR BOUGHT HIS BILL AS
AMENDED WITH MR STEINER SPILL.
BONTA STEINORTH BILL AND A
LESSER NEAR FINAL COMMENTS BACK
TO THE AUTHORS.
I JUST WANNA THE SECOND THAT THE
COMMENTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN.
REGARDING THAT TREMENDOUS WORK
THAT SUMMER STEINORTH HAS DONE
OVER THE YEARS AND PROUD TO BE
WORKING WITH HIM AND TEAMING UP
AND ON A BI PARTISAN EFFORT THAT
WE HOPE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL SO. I
THINK YOU SOME MEMBER STEINORTH
THANK YOU TO MISTER CHAIR AND
AND COLLEAGUES AND AND STAFF
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE OUT.
GREAT MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMEDIAN DRIVING
AND FIXATION. CHU HI CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHOI AYE AYE CHOI I
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE COOLEY MON.
THE MORE I WOULD.
THE MEASURES OUT.
VERY MUCH THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
CLICK HERE FOR OUR NEXT ITEM
MISTER KANSEN CHU.
THE WAY.
EXECUTIVES WHO CHAIRS OUR
MEMBERS HAVE FIRST OF ALL I
WANTED TO SAYING. THE CHAIR AND
THE COMEDIAN STAFF.
WHO'VE WORKING OF WAS ME AND MY
STAFF.
WELL ON ON THIS BILL AND I WILL
LOVE TO.
ASSEMBLY. COMMITTEE A COMEDIAN
AMENDMENT.
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
REQUIRES.
ALL USED MOBILE HOME PARKS
MOBILE HOME UNIT SO OR READ THE
TO HAVE SMOKE DETECTORS. CHO
SYSTEM WAS TO MOST RECENT STATE
FIRE MARSHAL STANDARD.
SECONDLY THIS BILL CREATE A
VOLUNTARY THING HOUSING
INSPECTION PROGRAM. FAULT FIRE
AND HEALTH HAZARD.
FOR RESIDENTS WITH A REASONABLE
CHARGE FOR SERVICES.
CERTAINLY THIS IS IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS TO.
DO A LANGUAGE ASSESS ABILITY
ISSUE AT THIS BILL.
WOULD REQUIRING ALL PARKS TO
MAKE TO PARK EVACUATION PLAN
AVAILABLE IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
ENGLISH AND AND.
NOT THAT I AM I MEDI CAL
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES FOR THE
COUNTY.
OR TO GO TO A FAKE THE
EVACUATION PLAN INTO A VERY
SIMPLE.
PICTURE A MAP  WOULD SOLVE
MUCH OF THE WORDING PHOTOS PEPO
DAFT ARE.
.
THEY USUALLY CHARGE A SECOND
LANGUAGES.
AND AND THIS BILL. IT CAME FROM
THE TRAGEDY OF SAN JOSE WOULD NO
DOUBT AND MANY A LOT OF PEOPLE.
A GUY.
LOST THEIR LIVES IN A MOBILE
HOME FIRE. BECAUSE OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE BUILDING AND
ALSO TO LAY ALL OF THE MOBILE
HOME PARK. IN RECENTLY AND SAN
JOSE OF A FAMILY ALL THREE GOT
KILLED. AND TWO OF THEM WERE
JUST YOUNG CHILDREN'S.
SO DISPELLED IS TRYING TO RE
IMPROVE AND I'M SURE THEY WILL
IMPROVE TO FIRE SAFETY FOR
RESIDENTS.
POTENTIAL SAVING LIVES
AND WAS ME TODAY I HAVE TO CELLS
A FIRE CHIEF ROBERSON PAEAN. AND
NICHOLAS CHVEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURING
HOME OWNERS LEE.
WHO SAT?
ROBERT.
THANK U.. ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT TWELVE
THIRTY THREE PM SAN JOSE FIRE
DEPARTMENT RESPONDED TO REPORTED
STRUCTURE FIRE INVOLVING A
MOBILE HOME AND ONE OF OUR NORTH
SAN IS A MOBILE HOME PARKS.
UPON ARRIVAL FIRE CREWS FOUND A
FULLY ENGULFED MOBILE HOME THAT
WAS EXTENDING.
TWO MOBILE HOMES ON EITHER SIDE.
SEARCH FOR OCCUPANTS WAS
PERFORMED.
ON THE ADJACENT MOBILE HOMES
HOWEVER FIRE CONDITIONS
PREVENTED. ENTRY INTO THE
INVOLVED UNIT.
MITIGATION EFFORTS PREVENTED
FURTHER SPREAD AND THE MAIN FIRE
WAS EXTINGUISHED.
AS THE SMOKE CLEARED FROM THE
HEAVILY DAMAGED.
STRUCTURE.
WITNESS WITNESS STATEMENTS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS STATEMENTS LED DO
A CAREFUL SEARCH FOR VICTIMS.
WITHIN A FEW HOURS IT WAS CLEAR
THAT AN ADULT MALE EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR. AND TWO JUVENILES AGES
NINE AND TEN HAD PERISHED.
I WANT TO BEGIN.
BY STATING THAT I AM CERTAIN
THAT SMOKE DETECTORS SAVE LIVES.
THE TRAGIC OUTCOME OF AUGUST
FIFTEENTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
IS REPRESENTATIVE OF THE REALITY
OF UNDETECTED FIRES IN OCCUPIED
BUILDINGS.
SURVIVABILITY IN AN ENCLOSED
ENVIRONMENT WHERE BREATHABLE AIR
IS CONSUMED AND REPLACED BY
CARBON MONOXIDE. IS REDUCED IN
SECONDS.
TOO OFTEN. THE OUTCOME IS
DETERMINED EVEN BEFORE THE BELL
STRIKES AT THE FIREHOUSE.
ONCE THE BELL STRIKES TIME IS OF
THE ESSENCE BUT IN THE CASE OF
MOBILE HOME PARKS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES.
NARROW ROADWAYS.
SINGLE ENTRY POINTS.
SPEED BUMPS
LIMITED WATER SUPPLY.
THESE ALL CHALLENGE OUR RESPONSE
TIMES.
ADDITIONALLY LIGHTWEIGHT
BUILDING MATERIALS PROVIDE
LITTLE FIRE RESISTANCE.
AND SMALL SPACES BECOME SMOKE
FILLED AND REACH HIGH
TEMPERATURES VERY QUICKLY.
I BELIEVE THAT OUR BEST CHANCE
AT SAVING LIVES FROM FIRE
PARTICULARLY IN THE MOBILE HOME
ENVIRONMENT IS THROUGH THE EARLY
DETECTION PROVIDED BY SMOKE
DETECTORS.
AND FURTHER.
STRENGTHENING SMOKE DETECTOR
REQUIREMENTS IN MOBILE HOMES
WERE REDUCE OUTCOMES LIKE THOSE
EXPERIENCED IN SAN JOSE. ON
AUGUST FIFTEENTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
TEAR MEMBERS.
NICHOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF THE
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE.
REPRESENTING SENIORS FOR
ENTRANCE IMMIGRANTS AND OTHER
LOW AND MODERATE.
AND FIXED HIM INCOME INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN MOBILE
HOME PARKS UPSTATE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT.
YOU WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
WHICH PROMOTES FIRE SAFETY
MOBILE HOME PARKS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THIS BILL REQUIRE ALL
MANUFACTURED HOMES TO HAVE THE
MOST UP TO DATE SMOKE ALARMS
INSTALLED AT THE POINT OF MOBILE
HIMSELF.
PARK OWNERS TO MAKE AN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLANS ASSESSABLE
RESIDENTS UPON THE QUEST OF
RESIDENTS IN THE SPOKEN LANGUAGE
BY THE RESIDENT UPON REQUEST.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL SETS UP A
FEE FOR SERVICE IN PUNITIVE
FREE.
OPPORTUNITY FOR RESIDENTS SEEK
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
RESPECT LAST FIAT VOTES.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
LET'S NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION.
POSSIBLE TO FOR FOR OUR
OPPONENTS TO SIT AT THE AT THE
TABLE.
THE GREAT.
JENNIFER SECOND HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS I'M WE WERE GONNA
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
BUT WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ALLEVIATE OUR
CONCERNS. AMENDMENT SO THAT ARE
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WILL SATISFY. OF OUR ISSUES WITH
THE BILL AND WE ARE NOW NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S KATHERINE BOARD WITH
THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND NAM.
YOU DON'T VERY SORRY ABOUT THAT
TRAGIC EVENT IN IN SAN JOSE.
I THINK THERE WERE A LOT OF
OTHER FACTORS THAT.
.
UNFORTUNATELY CONTRIBUTED TO
THE.
.
A FIRE IN THAT PARTICULAR MOBILE
HOME.
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT ARE.
IN THE IN THE BILL.
THEY'RE MORE FACTUAL AND POLICY
RELATED.
.
SECTION NUMBER ONES BEEN TAKEN
CARE OF AND AND WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AT THE.
AMENDMENTS THERE. SECTION TO
HAS TO DO WITH THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLANS THAT ARE
REQUIRED BY.
MOBILE HOME PARKS TO CREATE.
DOT HAS BEEN ON THE STATUTE FOR
A LONG TIME BUT IN BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE.
I'M WE AGREED WITH A SENATOR
PATEA TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THESE PLANS WERE
AVAILABLE READILY THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY. ON THE INTENT THERE
AND IT STATED IN SP TWENTY THREE
IS THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
THE OWNER.
OR OPERATOR MOBILE HOME PARK OR
MANUFACTURED HOME COMMUNITY
COMMUNICATE TO RESIDENTS
ESSENTIALLY VACUOUS XIN ROOTS
AND BASIC EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
INFORMATION. IN A MANNER
APPROPRIATE TO THE COMMUNITY IT
IS NOT THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
THAT AN OWNER OR OPERATOR BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PHYSICALLY
EVACUATING RESIDENTS FROM THEIR
HOMES DURING EMERGENCY.
IT'S FOR THE AND FURTHER THE
INTENT THAT THE RESIDENTS TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEMSELVES DURING AN EMERGENCY.
THESE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PLANS ARE ARE RATHER LARGE.
HERE'S ONE FROM RANCHO
CALISTOGA HERE'S ANOTHER ONE
FROM OUT TO LOOK ANNA.
HERE'S THE ONE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AMER NAM OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES PUTS
TOGETHER.
AND.
OUR MOBILE HOME PARKS USES A
TEMPLATE TO. CREATE THESE TYPE
OF PLANS.
ALL THESE PLANS HAVE TO BE
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FOR THEIR APPROVAL
FOR OUR.
FOR OUR OUR PERMIT TO OPERATE.
IF.
WE'RE REQUIRED TO DO ADDITIONAL
PLANS IN OTHER LANGUAGES WHICH
IS WHICH IS A GREAT CALL I MEAN
I WHO WOULD NOT WANT TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE. EVERYTHING IN ANY
LANGUAGE THAT PEOPLE NEED TO.
RETAIN ESPECIALLY EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS STUFF.
BUT WE JUST DON'T HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT THESE PLANTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT THERE ARE FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR MOBILE HOME PARKS IN THE
STATE.
IF WE ARE REQUIRED TO MAKE FIVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND EVERY
SINGLE PARK.
THEY'RE GONNA BE TO.
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PLANS
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THEIR APPROVAL AND LOOKING AND
READING ALL THE LINGUISTICS AND
DIFFERENT DIALECTS AND DIFFERENT
ISSUES WITH REGARD TO THOSE
PLANS.
I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S EITHER
BETTER FOR.
YES TO CREATE SOME.
.
GENERIC EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PLANS IN THOSE FIVE LANGUAGES
OR.
IN A LOT OF THESE PLANS WE'D
DIRECT RESIDENTS TO GO TO
CERTAIN WEBSITES SO ON THE
FEMALE WEBSITE A READY DOT GOV.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
BROCHURES EMERGENCY SUPPLY LESS
IN ALL SORTS OF LANGUAGES THAT
ARE FREE ON THEIR WEBSITE SO
PEOPLE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF.
FREE SERVICES BY THE GOVERNMENT
SINCE THEY HAVE THE MORE MORE
MONEYS AND ABILITIES TO
TRANSLATE. GET THOSE DIALECTS
RIGHT GET THE INFORMATION RIGHT.
YOU KNOW THE MAPS THAT WE
PROVIDE FOR EVACUATION ARE.
PRETTY UNDERSTANDABLE IN ANY
LANGUAGE IF YOU GO TO DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES.
YOU KNOW YOU OR THE BACK OF THE
DOOR YOU'VE GOT YOUR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS.
IN YOU KNOW EVACUATION EXIT AND
IT'S PRETTY. EXPLANATORY WITH
ARROWS AND GET NOW. ON THE LAST
WEEK THE THE LAST PART OF THE
BILL HAS TO DO WITH.
THE THE BILL CODIFIES A
REGULATION.
AND THE REGULATION IS ALREADY ON
THE BOOKS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CAN COME OUT AND
INSPECT A PERSON'S HOME OR
MOBILE HOME PARK. FOR A FOR A
SERVICE FEE WHICH IS CURRENTLY A
HUNDRED NINETY SIX DOLLARS AN
HOUR. IT'S DONE ON A TIME AND
MOTION STUDY THAT WAS DONE ABOUT
TEN YEARS AGO SO EVEN THEN. WHAT
THEY'RE CHARGING IS NOT?
APPROPRIATE FOR TODAY'S LEVEL
OF FUN OF PERSONNEL SO THE MAIN
REASON WHY THOSE INSPECTIONS
DON'T HAPPEN ON A REQUEST BASIS.
IS THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
INSPECTORS THERE ARE FIFTY THREE
FUNDED INSPECTORS FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
SO THAT'S FIVE LESS THAN
COUNTIES WILL THEIR SEVEN
VACANCIES AMONG THE FIFTY THREE.
SO IT AND THEN PUT ON TOP OF
THAT.
ONLY FIVE PERCENT OF MOBILE HOME
PARKS ARE BEING INSPECTED
CURRENTLY.
THAT THERE IS A FEE THAT CREATES
THESE INSPECTORS IT'S A FOUR
DOLLAR FEE. WHEN THE MOBILE HOME
PARKS ACT
SHE'LL BE EXCLUSIVELY USED FOR
INSPECTION OF MOBILE HOME PARKS
AND MOBILE HOMES TO DETERMINE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MOBILE HOME
PARKS ACT.
SO.
WE QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ANY MONEY THERE FOR
INSPECTORS TO DO STE THINGS
OUTSIDE OF THE MOBILE HOME PARK
INSPECTION.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE ASKING THESE
INSPECTORS TO COME IN. AND NOT
SITE.
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS AND
NOTS ON BUT IN THE ANALYSIS
SAYS.
THE VIOLATION OF THE MPA IS
FOUND IN THE COURSE OF
INSPECTION AGE CITY CANNOT
IMPOSE A PENALTY.
SO IF IN FACT.
AT AGE CITY INSPECTOR CAME INTO
SOMEBODY'S HOME FOUND MAYBE A
PROPANE BARBECUE IN THERE. AND
SAID HEY THIS IS REALLY YOU
NOTICES A REALLY BAD CASE SOME
AND USE TO GET THAT BARBECUE OUT
WE'RE GONNA CITE YOU FOR IT.
THE THEY CAN'T DO THAT ACCORDING
TO THE SPILL SO IT NOW YOU'RE
PUTTING INSPECTORS INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO TURN A BLIND EYE TO. BAD
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE. SO FOR
ALL THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
MS A MONTH THINK YOU I THINK YOU
HAVE FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
REGRETTABLY THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT AND SO INTIMATE WITH.
IN TERMS OF EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS AND I TOO HAVE
BEEN EXPLORING AYE.
WHAT EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS
MEAN TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS ON A
BROADER LEVEL AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF ALSO MAKING SURE THAT THIS
COMMUNICATION IS IN LANGUAGES
THAT ARE UNDERSTOOD?
IT WAS A REAL ISSUE IN OUR
DISTRICT AND WE ARE DEFINITELY
EXPLORING HOW COUNTIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES CAN BE INVOLVED.
AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT EASY
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT AND WE
NEED TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE BEST
METHOD IS WHO DOES A HOW WE DO
IT HOW FAST HE GETS OUT.
WHAT IS THE MODE OF
COMMUNICATION?
BUT I DO THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION AND THIS BILL
MOVING BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION REGRETTABLY WE
WILL BE IN SPACES WHERE IT CAN
BE MORE CHALLENGING SO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL HAPPEN
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND JUST.
REITERATE HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS
I'M NOT JUST TO SAVE THE LIVES
OF THAT PERSON WHO MIGHT BE
IMPACTED BUT ALL OF THOSE IN THE
AREA IN TERMS OF EVACUATION SO
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ERA CAN I
RESPOND OUR TRAVEL YOU WILL KEEP
THIS COMPETITION GOING I NOTE IT
IS.
IT VERY CHALLENGING OF TO
TRANSLATE ALL THOSE.
HIM EMERGE EMERGENCY YOU'VE
ACTUALLY EVACUATION PLAN.
BUT I WANT YOU TO FOCUS ON THIS
FIRE A AS YOU BACK WHO XIN PLAN.
SO YOU DON'T WE LOOK FOR CAN
HELP A A A PICTURE A MAP.
AND THAT WE REQUIRED THE. THE
DAYS RESIDENT TO
POSTED ON A BACK UP THE DOORS.
AND OF I THINK WILL BE A VERY.
LOCAL SOLUTION FOR THE FIRST
STOP BUT I JUST WANT. TO SAY
THAT PUBLICLY I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH LOUIS
YOU. AND ANY OPPOSITION TO MAKE
IT.
SOME POLL. NOT NOT THAT COSTLY.
AND BE ABLE TO SAVE LIVES.
THERE YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT.
MR MAGI.
I THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR UMPIRE AND PLEASE
HEAR THE AUTHORS SAY THEY'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
DEPARTMENTS AMID A SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I I'M SUPPORTIVE
OF THE GOAL. OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AYE BUT.
I THINK THE OPPOSITION RAY
SEVERAL.
VERY PERTINENT POINTS.
.
THE LACK OF INSPECTORS MEAN TO.
IT IS SIGNIFICANT.
TO JUST.
CREATE SOMETHING THAT HAS NO
THAT IS GONNA OF NO PRACTICAL
EFFECT BECAUSE IT CAN'T BE
ENFORCED. IS A WASTE OF
EVERYBODY'S TIME AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S THE GOALS OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE I
THINK WHAT EVERYBODY ON THIS
THIS BODY STRATEGY WHICH IS NOT
HAVE THESE TRACK?
I THOUGHT THE IDEA OF A WEBSITE
YOU SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES
MINUTES FOR SEPARATE BUT TODAY
BY THINGS PRETTY GOOD IDEA I
MEAN THERE'S SOME THINGS I THINK
THAT. THAT COULD BE DONE THAT
WOULD ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL BUT IT
WOULD STILL BE LESS BURDENSOME
AND AND WOULD PROBABLY LONG TERM
BE MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE SO.
I'D I'M PLEASED THE AYE AYE
WILL SPUR DAY BECAUSE OF YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THESE ISSUES BUT.
IN PARTICULAR ON THOSE
INSPECTORS.
THAT I THINK THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE
RESOLVED AND YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
SOME FEE GOING TO PAY THESE
INSPECTORS AND THEN THERE'S NO
INSPECTORS. AND IT BEGS THE
QUESTION AS TO WHERE IS THIS BE
GOING. UP AND I THINK THAT NEEDS
TO BE TRACKED DOWN AS WELL TO
SELL.
MISTER GLORIA. JACOBS CHANGES TO
BELABOR THE POINT I I FOUND AND
I THINK IS ON POINT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHIU FOR FOR AGREEING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK.
WAY IF IT IS BORING I END UP
HER CLIENTS TO MAKE SURE THE
SEXISM IT'S PRACTICAL
IMPLEMENTABLE AND SO THAT'S THE
PRICE OF THE BUDGET PROCESS IS
WELL MAKING SURE THOSE
POSITIONS%
ARE FILLED.
IN THE WORK CAN ACTUALLY BE
DONE THE BAD ACTORS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THE GOOD FOLKS
WE WE SHARED OUR GOAL OF
ENSURING
THAT. OUR MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE
ARE SAFE AND THAT RESIDENTS ARE
PREPARED IN CASE OF THE WORST
EMERGENCY. A AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'RE DOING
TO ENSURE THAT YOUR CONSTITUENTS
GIVEN THE TRAGEDY THAT HAPPENED
IN YOUR DISTRICT.
IS NOT REPEATED EVEN YOUR
DISTRICT ARE ANYWHERE AROUND THE
STATE.
I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
WITH OUR STAFF ON AMENDMENTS AND
AGREED TO THE AMENDMENTS AND I
WILL REITERATE I THINK WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OUR COMMITTEE
WHICH HAS.
I THINK THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
BROUGHT UP SOME ISSUES ARE THAT
WILL HELP IMPROVE THE BILL TO
MAKE IT MORE WORKABLE FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT AND. THAT IS
WHAT I UNDERSTAND TO BE THE.
PERSPECTIVE OF THE OPPOSITION
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO ENGAGE WITH THEM AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE WANT TO SEE A BILL
THAT IS WORKABLE AND THAT
ADDRESSES THE NEED AND. ARE
CERTAINLY IS SOMEONE WHO IS
AUTHORED LANGUAGE ACCESS BILLS
BEFORE I SHARE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
RESIDENTS RECEIVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED. IN THE
LANGUAGE LANGUAGES THAT.
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND.
BUT THAT WE DON'T CREATE UNDUE
BURDEN AROUND THAT SO.
IN ADDITION TO STAFFING ISSUES.
I DO KNOW AND BELIEVE THAT YOU
WILL WORK THROUGH THESE ISSUES
SO WITH THAT. OF WITH THE
AMENDMENT SO I HAVE A AYE REKO
THAT WE MOVE THIS BILL FOR IS
OUR MOTION WITH IT FOR.
AND SIR SECOND.
SECOND OF.
SHE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE PROTECT
YOUR BERMAN SHOWN AGAIN SAYING
SAWYER.
THAT YOUR COMEDIAN AND HIS CHAIR
FOR YOUR ARE IMPERFECT AND AND
YOU AGAIN YOU HAVE MY WORD I
WILL WORK CLOSELY OPPOSITION TO
MAKE IT.
PARTICLE AND DOABLE AND TO SAY
FLAG THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ASK
FOR YOUR RIGHTS.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED INJURY
DIVERSITY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU AYE CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAU.
SHALL I CHOI.
CHILE NO GLORIA. GLORIA AYE LEE
MONTH THE MONTH I WOULD.
GOOD I.
YOUR BILL IS OUT.
YOU VERY MUCH CHECK HERE AND
WITHOUT IN ASKING MISTER GORE'S
PREPARED TO.
MR COLOR FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AYE I
WILL WANT TO BEGIN THIS MORNING
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS OF FOR A. B. TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO. I'D DAHLE
APPRECIATION TO THE STAFF. WEBER
RUNNING THEME THIS MORNING
OBVIOUSLY OF THOSE A SURPLUS OF
TO YOUR TEAM. IS CHAIRMAN OF
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE I TO MAKE
AT THE COST HOUSING ACT EVEN
BETTER.
AS YOU AND I EVERY COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND REALLY EVERYONE IN
THIS BUILDING KNOWS A WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF A SIGNIFICANT
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN
THE STATE'S PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING. A CONTINUES TO FAIL TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO
INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE AND LOW
INCOME HOUSING ALONG TRANSIT
PRIORITY QUARTERS. NOW THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A STATEWIDE OPT IN
PROGRAM THAT AMENDS DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS TO ALLOW FOR THE USE
OF FLOOR AREA RATIO OR FAR.
BASED CALCULATION SYSTEM FOR THE
CREATION OF NEW RESIDENTIAL
UNITS
NOW I THINK ALMOST ALL YOU
CERTAIN LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO YOU
MAY KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS BUT FOR
THOSE WHO NOW. A BASICALLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF MORE
SMALLER UNITS WILL BE BUILT THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE ALLOWED UNDER
CURRENT RULES.
TWENTY PERCENT OF THESE UNITS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO BE AT OR
BELOW FIFTY IT FIFTY PERCENT
AREA MEDIAN INCOME OR A MI. AND
REMAIN AT THAT AFFORDABILITY
LEVEL FOR UP TO FIFTY FIVE YEARS
SIMILAR TO THE DENSITY BONUS LAW
THAT IS ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS.
THE AMENDMENTS ADD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING REPLACEMENT REQUIREMENTS
A TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T LOSE
EXISTING WORKFORCE HOUSING.
THE BILL ALSO MAINTAINS A
DEVELOPER'S REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR
CONCESSIONS AND INCENTIVES THAT
ARE GRANTED UNDER THE DEAD SEA
BONUS LAW HOWEVER THE HEIGHT OF
THE PROJECT WILL
STILL BE REGULATED BY UNDERMINE
BASE ZONING.
ACOSTA HOUSING ACT DOES NOT USE
A PUBLICLY FUNDED DOLLARS TO
SUBSIDIZE THE FAA ARE BASED
PROGRAM ACTUALLY CREATE A MARKET
INCENTIVE AT THE CREATION OF
THESE LOW INCOME UNITS. ME THAT
WE'RE NOT UTILIZING ARE SCARCE.
SUBSIDY DOLLARS OF FOR THESE
PROJECTS THOSE CAN CONTINUE FOR
TO OTHER MORE TRADITIONAL
PROJECTS ON THE MARKET RATE
HOUSING HELPS TO SUPPORT THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING I IN THIS
PROPOSAL. SO AS THE BILL MOVES
TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE I WILL ADD
A FORMULA THAT WILL PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO USE THIS
FLOOR AREA CHICAGO NATION SYSTEM
OF FOR CLARITY SAKE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEMI TO ADDS
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING PRODUCTION TOOL BOX WE
WILL NEED AT ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION NEW HOMES BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THIS BILL WILL HELP
MAKE IT DAY IN THAT VERY LARGE
NUMBER WITH ME TODAY I HAVE TO
IT OF WITNESSES OF FIRST MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO THAT
SAID YOU SEE COUNCIL MEMBER AND
I SHOULD SAY TO CHECK NEW CHAIR
OF THE METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
SYSTEM. OF THIS IS BILL IS VERY
MUCH THE CONVERGENCE OF HOUSING
AND TRANSPORTATION A DOT COMS
MEMBER GEORGIA GOMEZ WHO
ORIGINATED OR CAME UP WITH THIS
IDEA. AS WAS MORE TOP WAS
REPRESENTING THE BILL SPONSORED
WHICH THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA BEEN FAULKNER AND THE
ENTIRE CITY.
CITY COUNCIL OF SAN DIEGO AS
MENTIONED WE ARE THE SPONSORS
TODAY AND WITH ME IS COUNCIL
MEMBER GOMEZ OF FROM THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO.
THINK YOU AND I THINK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO LA THE CASA ACT
TODAY. I WOULD LIKE BY FIRST
LIKE TO THINK I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND MY STAFF TO MAKING
THIS BILL REALITY. IN SAN DIEGO
WHERE I REPRESENT COUNCIL
DISTRICT NINE WE ARE STRUGGLING
TO BUILD SUFFICIENT HOUSE SEEM
TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF OUR
RESIDENTS.
BUT AS MANY OF YOU CAN ATTEST
THIS IS ALSO THE CASE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE HERE
BRINGING THAT FORWARD TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE WITHIN OPTIM
PROGRAM FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
WE NEED NEW TOOLS AND INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
TO TRY TO SOLVE OUR LACK OF
HOUSING.
AND IN PARTICULAR AWAY TO
INCREASE OR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
IF WE WANT TO SEEK MORE
AFFORDABLE AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE
BUILDING DENSER MORE. A COMPACT
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS NEAR
TRANSIT.
THE CASA ADD DOES JUST THAT BY
ALLOWING DEAL DEVELOPERS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE HOW MANY
UNITS THEY CAN BUILD. RATHER
THAN CAP INTENSITY THROUGH OUR
TRADITIONAL MEASUREMENT SYSTEMS
OF DWELLING UNITS PER ACRE.
WHERE TRADITIONALLY A LOT WOULD
BE RESTRICTED TO A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF DWELLING UNITS PER
ACRE? THIS WILL ALLOW MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING SOUNDS TO SET A
FLOOR AREA RATIO BONUS LEAVING
IT UP TO THE DEVELOPERS TO
REALLY MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
UNITS ON SITE.
BUT CASA ACT
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO REALIZE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN HOUSING
UNITS. IN THE APPROPRIATE
STONE'S ALONG TRANSIT QUARTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
PARTICULARLY ASK IF THERE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
YEAH THE MARINO I AM OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE THE BILL
BROUGHT INTO REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO GRANT THE FAR
BONUS AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
DENSITY BONUS.
AS WELL AS AS THE CALCULATIONS
FOR THE FART WHAT THE FAR BONUS
LOOKS LIKE GOES INTO THE BALLOT
SURE THAT THAT IS. COMMENSURATE
WITH WHAT AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS ARE. AREN'T ABOUT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER.
ASSISTANCE AND ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SHAUN TO PICKING THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
KYLE JOINS US HERE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH A SUPPORTING CONCEPT I'M
NOT REGULARLY ARE WE HOSPITAL
FOR TO SAY HOW THIS BILL GETS
WORKED UP OVER SUPPORT THE GULF
THANK YOU.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS PACMAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
RIPPED FROM THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I'M BRIAN BECAUSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE AND OUR
COLLEAGUES AT WESTERN CENTER
BEEN LOOKING AT THIS BILL AND
TALKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS.
WE THINK IT'S HEADING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION WE STILL TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND ITS INTERACTION
WITH AND SEE BONUS ON MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT. UNDERMINING THE
EXISTING BALANCE THERE WHILE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE THE THE
AUTHORS OBJECTIVE SO WE LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON. IT WITH
THE AUTHOR WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION YET BUT WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET THERE
THANKS.
IT'S BEEN A MOTION WITH THE
BILL'S A SECOND.
ANY FOR THEIR SUPPORT IS ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS MR
MAIENSCHEIN.
WELL THANK YOU IT'S
A GREAT DAY WHEN I CAN SCORE A
CITY SANDIEGO BELL SERVICES
STARTING MY DAY OFF WELTER INTO.
YOU HAVE A GENIUS BILL LIKE THIS
COMING FROM A GREAT CITY SO. I'M
I'M I'M VERY HAPPY TO DO SO I A
COUPLE BRIEF COMMENTS AT WHAT
MISS GOMEZ AT AS WELL.
I KNOW YOU'RE ANXIOUSLY WAITING
TO GET BACK TO SAN DIEGO AS BOTH
TODD AND I ARE AS WELL TO SOME.
.
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THAT MISSED
Y. THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR GREAT
WORK ON THIS OF ALL YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
YOU KNOW THE OPT IN PROVISION I
THINK IS SIGNIFICANT YOU AND I
ARE GOING TO BE GOOD EXAMPLES OF
THAT WITH THE DEBT THE DISTRICTS
WE REPRESENTED WHEN WE ARE ON
THE CITY.
IF YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR DISTRICT
HAS
MANY MORE TRANSIT FOR EXAMPLE
MANY MORE TRANSIT OPTIONS. THAN
WE DO I TO GET FROM IN A RANCH
FOR OUR SCRIPTS RANCH TO HELP
CRAFT STORE EVEN WORSE STEP
POINT LOMA OUR SUMMER THERE IS
REALLY.
IN TERMS OF TRANSIT CHOICE IT IS
REALLY AN IMPOSSIBILITY ALMOST
ARM AND AND AND. AS SUCH IS NOT
UTILIZED BECAUSE TO GET THERE IS
A YOU KNOW TWO HOUR BUS RIDE
WITH FOR TRANSFERS AND SO AS A
AS A RESULT NO ONE DOES IT.
SO I THINK HAVING THAT OPT IN.
AT UPTON IS VERY SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE AS THESE REGIONS HAVE
DIFFERENT. DIFFERENT NEEDS AYE
AND DIFFERENT ABILITIES TO DO
THIS A AND M. IS COMES TO I
THINK YOU HAVE SOME AN HOUR I
DON'T KNOW THE EXACT PERSON
BETWEEN HIM SQUARE BUT YOU HAVE
SOME.
THE POLICEMAN BETTER TRANSIT OP
OPTIONS BUT SOME PROBLEM MORE
DIFFICULT HOUSING OPTIONS
SO I THINK THIS SORT OF
ADDRESSES THAT.
THAT BALANCE VERY VERY WELL.
AND I THINK IT'S A UNIQUE
APPROACH TO TRY TO GET OUT ACT
TO TRY TO GET A PROBLEM OF HOW
TO INCREASE HOUSING STOCK BUT
HAD WE DO SO IN A WAY. THAT
DOESN'T TRAP PEOPLE.
IN A SITUATION THAT WOULD BE
UNSUSTAINABLE BOTH IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY DEAL WITH EMPLOYMENT
BUT ALSO HOW TO DEAL WITH YOU
KNOW.
HOW TO GET AROUND ON A WEEKEND
OR YOU KNOW I'D LOVE TO AS
SOMEBODY WHO'S?
YOU KNOW TRAIPSING AROUND WITH
TWO TEENAGE DAUGHTERS TO ALL
THEIR STUFF ON THE WEEKENDS I'D
I WISH WE HAD MORE TO YOU KNOW.
BE GREATEST ANIMATRONIC.
AT LEAST NOT.
BUT I.
SO ANYWAY I APPLAUD THIS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
AND THE FORTY GETTING. THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
MISS THE MARK UP DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS
GOTCHA YOU SECOND THE MOTION
LET ME SAY A FEW WORDS.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AS
WELL AS YOUR SPONSORS FOR THIS
VERY CREATIVE APPROACH TO
INCENTIVIZING. HOUSING AROUND
TRANSIT INTO FORCE IN ALL OF US
TO.
DUST UPON IF WE ARE.
AND PLANNING AND ZONING LAWS
AGAIN.
I ALSO THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF
ON THE AMENDMENTS PARTICULARLY
FOR GREEN TO ADD THE. NO NET
LOSS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIREMENT THAT IS FOUND IN
DENSITY BONUS I THINK THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO. A ASSURING
COMMUNITIES OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT WE NOT ONLY IN THIS CRISIS
NEED TO INCENTIVIZE THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING BUT NEED
TO INCENTIVIZE IT AROUND
TRANSIT.
THAT IS TRUE SMART GROWTH AND
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE AND WITH THAT.
AND PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS.
WITH A STRONG AYE RECORD TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD.
WITH THAT MISTER GLORY OF ANY
FINAL COMMENTS JUST APPRECIATION
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THOSE
COMMENTS WAS MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
AND A LITTLE EXCITEMENT THIS
BILL APPRECIATION TO COUNTS
MEMBER GOMEZ FOR COMING UP HERE.
TO HELP PRESENT THE BILL IT'S.
AGAIN HER IDEA AND I'M REALLY
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
HER TO GET THIS DONE. OUSLEY
WOULD TALK ABOUT BILLY MORE
HOUSING FOR WORKING CALIFORNIA'S
PEOPLE MAKING THIRTY FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE A LOT MORE THAT HOUSING THIS
DO THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE.
GREAT.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY COULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. CHU HI I
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAU. CHAU AYE CHOI AYE AYE CHOI
AYE GLORIA AYE AYE.
WE MONTH.
LIMA I.
WOOD. WHICH I.
YOUR MEASURES OUT.
WE'VE ONE FINAL ITEM AND THAT IS
MINDS AT THIS TIME I'M GONNA
TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR NEW
VICE CHAIR.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
SEAT WHEN YOU. ARE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES.
IN THE MIDST OF THE WORST
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY THIS BILL WOULD RECREATE
REDEVELOPMENT AS A TOOL TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ON A REDUCED SCALE AND
WITH SIGNIFICANT STATE OVERSIGHT
COMPARED TO FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
I KNOW I THINK IS.
I THINK EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
YOU UNDERSTOOD.
THE CHALLENGES ARE AND WHAT
REDEVELOPMENT PROVIDED TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
DURING THE PROP THIRTEEN ERA
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
WERE CRITICAL FUNNY TOOL FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOUSING.
AT THE TIME OF THEIR LIMITATION
RDAS REQUIRED TO SPEND A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STATEWIDE
WHICH MEANT. WE LOST A BILLION
DOLLARS YEAR WHEN REDEVELOPMENT
WAS ENDED.
I IN EVERY PART OF THE STATE.
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
CROSSES PARTISAN DIVIDES OUR
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT
INTEREST IN BRINGING BACK TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING TOOLS ARE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING.
THE INTENSE NEEDS AROUND HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AB THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN WOULD
ALLOW THE CITY TO CREATE A
REDEVELOPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HOUSING AGENCY.
THIRTY PERCENT THE MONIES
GENERATED ANY PROJECT AREA MUST
GO TO FUND HOUSING THIS COMPARES
TO TWENTY PERCENT FOR FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES.
WHILE ALL TAXING ENTITIES THAT
RECEIVE PROPERTY TAXES
CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION TO PARTICIPATE.
THE BILL WOULD MAKE COUNTIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS HOLE THROUGH
PASS THROUGH PAYMENTS AND THE
STATE WOULD BACK FILL FUNDS
DIVERTED FROM SCHOOLS UNDER PROP
NINETY EIGHT OBLIGATIONS.
ANY NEW AGENCY WOULD APPLY TO
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL FOR
REVIEW OF WHETHER PROPOSED
ACTIVITY SUPPORT THE STATE'S
GOAL OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION.
THE SGC WOULD MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE PART OF
FINANCE WHO WOULD DETERMINE THE
FINAL APPROVAL. ALSO MENTION
THIS BILL INCLUDES A CAP ON HOW
MUCH THE STATE WOULD CONTRIBUTE
EACH YEAR TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
A CONTROL ON THE SIZE OF THIS
NEW VERSION OF REDEVELOPMENT.
AND THAT IT WILL GROW TO THE
SCALE OF FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
THAT AMOUNT IS CURRENTLY BLANK
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
RIGHT AMOUNT.
TO AVOID EGREGIOUS ABUSES THAT
SOME FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES HAD EXPERIENCE LIKE
SPENDING MONEYS ON STRIP MALLS
OR GOLF COURSES.
AB THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN ALSO
INCLUDE A NUMBER SIGNIFICANT
SAFEGUARDS INCLUDING ROBUST ANTI
DISPLACEMENT POLICIES DETAILED
RECORD KEEPING REQUIREMENTS.
INDEPENDENT ANNUAL AUDITS AND
HARSH FINANCIAL PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS.
I DON'T THINK THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE ENGAGE ON
THIS INCLUDING THE DIVERSITY OR
ASSEMBLY.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER IN A WORKING GROUP TO
FINE TUNE THIS PROPOSAL.
AGAIN WITH BROAD SUPPORT.
FROM AROUND THE STATE IN CLOSING
THIS IS A BILL THAT IS A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO RE ESTABLISH
REDEVELOPMENT BUT TO DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY ON A LIMITED SCALE.
FOCUSED ON OUR STATES PRIORITIES
AND WITH REAL OVERSIGHT AND
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OUT FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MARINO I OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE IN CONCEPT.
AND PLEASED TO SEE A
INTRODUCTION OF A TRUE
REDEVELOPMENT BELL.
AS YOU MAY HAVE REMEMBERED
SIEGE SUSAN ARDENT SUPPORTER OF
REDEVELOPMENT AND THE ROLE IT
PLAYED IN BOTH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS FOR
THE STATE OVERSIGHT PIECE BUT WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BEING
RESTED IN THE HANDS OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BRIAN AUGUST ON DEATH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION WE TO ARE SUPPORTIVE
IN CONCEPT THERE SOME KEY
DETAILS TO BE WORKED OUT AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO ENSURE
THAT WE. MAXIMIZE THE PRODUCTION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THAT.
I KNOW LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY ALSO
SUPPORTIVE IN CONCEPT WE APPLIED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO FOR BEING
WILLING TO BRING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD. WE CLEARLY SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF BRINGING BACK A
REDEVELOPMENT TYPE TOOL.
AND JUST.
NEED TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THE DETAILS AND VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH THOSE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
SO AS A MATTER NOW WITH WHAT HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS PART ABOUT
THINKING.
TERM BUCKLEY HOUSING CALIFORNIA
ALSO SPORTING CONCEPT THAT WE
APPLY.
THAT LEADERSHIP OF THIS A
MEMBER ON THIS EFFORT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING OUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS BILL.
PHYLLIS ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
SHOT OF BACON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DENKER
GUMMY HELPFULLY CALIFORNIA
CITIES WERE PART OF THE SPORT
AND CONCEPT BY LYING. NAM IF YOU
WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE.
THE AUTHOR THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE TAKEN A LEADERSHIP
POSITION ON THE US ON.
YOU KNOW IT IT OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
RECOGNITION THAT ARE
REDEVELOPMENT PLAYED REALLY
CRITICAL ROLE IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND AND THERE WERE A
LOT OF A POLICY BENEFITS OUT FOR
THE STATE. ARM WHILE WE HAVE
THESE NEW TOOLS OUT THERE AND
THE LEAGUE SUPPORTED DEL A
NUMBER OF THOSE TOOLS THEY
REALLY DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
LIFT THAT THE PRIOR TOOL HADN'T
AND I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO GET BACK TO THAT. ARE
IN ALSO.
THEIR WATER COMMENT THIS LOT OF
COMMON GROUND BETWEEN CITIES IN
THE STATE TERMS OF POLICIES
WHETHER STUDIO. HOUSING EXCEPT
FOR.
I THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
WERE GOING TO BE LOOKING OUT AS
AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON ON THIS
IS YOU KNOW AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE NEED TO HAVE A TOOL
THAT'S UNDERSTANDABLE AND AND
THAT OBVIOUSLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD WANT TO HAVE TO INITIATE.
USE SO NEEDS TO BE OF YOU TO US.
THAT YOU KNOW LEAST.
YOU NOT NOT TOO ONEROUS IN
TERMS OF THE CONDITIONS AND THEN
DEPENDABLE OF FUNDING.
IF THE FUNDING IS COMMITTED HE
CAN'T BE TAKEN AWAY THAT THAT'S
PART OF THE LEGACY OF THE PRIOR
REDEVELOPMENT THE RISK OF RATES
BUDGET RAIDS ON ON REDEVELOPMENT
FUNDING. IT NEEDS IF THERE'S
FUNDING AND IS TO BE DEPENDABLE
SO WE CAN RELY ON A GOING
FORWARD. IN THE DETAILS AND
CONDITIONS THIS IS GOING TO BE A
FORTY FORTY FIVE YEAR ENDEAVOR.
LET'S LET'S SET THE RULES LET'S
TELL THEM WHAT THEY ARE AND
WHAT'S NOT CHANGE THEM AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO PEOPLE CAN CAN
RELY ON THEM SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON THIS MEASURE AND.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
LEADERSHIP.
TIFFANY FAN BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO WE ARE AYE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT
REMEMBER STORY THE JOBS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES HAVE A CONCERNS
POSITIONS ARE KIND ABOUT TWEENER
AREA. I MEAN WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THEIR DIALOGUE WE'VE
HAD WITH THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
I'M TO DATE YOU KNOW THIS IS A
REALLY MEATY BILL BUILDING ON
THE SKELETON WE THINK OF FORMER
RDAS AND.
UNFORTUNATE OUR CONCERNS ARE
BASED ON THE BROADER PROMISE OF
THE COMPELLED PARTICIPATION OF
ALL LOCAL AGENCIES RATHER THAN
THE WILLFUL.
PARTICIPATION AND WE DO HAVE
SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE
DRAFTING OF THE MEASURE BUT WE
BELIEVE.
.
WE ARE WILL KEEP CONTINUE TO
WORK I'M TO GET THROUGH THOSE
PROBLEMS AND SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE ISSUE OF LOCAL AGENCIES
COUNTIES NOT BE MADE WHOLE IN
THIS PROCESS.
AND AS A SHARE DURING
INFORMATIONAL HEARING EARLIER
THIS YEAR.
AND IT'S BEEN A LONG STANDING.
POLICY POSITION IS THAT WE MUST
HAVE.
WILLFUL CONSENT FROM ALL
AGENCIES IN THIS AREA BECAUSE
OTHERWISE RESIDENTIALLY TAKING
REVENUE FROM A LOCAL AGENCY
COUNTY IS A PROVIDE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND GIVEN IT TO A
CITY. FOR THEIR PURPOSES AND WE
JUST THINK THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO TO REALLY PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND LONG TERM COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT SO WE HAVE A
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M ANTHONY TOWN HALL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
AS YOU KNOW IT'S PROBABLY NO
SPECIAL DISTRICTS
I PROVIDE ESSENTIAL FRONTLINE
LOCAL SERVICES FROM. IT WATER
AND FLATTENED TO A PARKS AND
HEALTH CARE. AND WE SHARE.
THE SAME CONCERNS AS OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE COUNTY.
WHERE THE?
THE HOW BUREAUCRACY IS NOT
CONSENSUAL SO WHERE WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE ON. A ON ON THE
NEW I AGENCY BUT WE WEREN'T
THERE BY CONSENT.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
PASS THROUGH HOUSE MINISTER BY
THE STATE AND IT'S NOT CLEAR
THAT IT ACTUALLY MAKES THIS
WHOLE.
SHE COULD JEOPARDIZE LOCAL
SERVICES
I ONE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING A LEADERSHIP ROLE ON
THESE BIG ISSUES AND BEING OPEN
TO THE DISCUSSION. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO TO DO
THAT TO WORK THESE ISSUES OUT SO
WE ALSO IN A CONCERNS.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU I'M HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ALSO JUST
EXPRESSING CONCERNS.
IT'S NO SECRET FOR THOSE WHO'VE
BEEN AROUND THIS CAPITAL WHILE
THAT WE'VE PARTNERED WITH THE
GOVERNOR IN ELIMINATING
REDEVELOPMENT NOT BECAUSE OF ITS
EXISTING GOAL TO. REMOVE BLIGHT
AND HELP PROMOTE THE DEVELOPMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE EMBRACE
THAT GOAL OUR FIREFIGHTERS CAN'T
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY WORK IT'S IMPORTANT POLICY
GOAL. WE'RE JUST CONCERNED THAT
THIS MISSES THE MARK AND WILL A.
YOU KNOW NOT ALLOW SPECIAL
DISTRICTS FIRE DISTRICTS TO HAVE
A SAY IN WHERE THEIR PROPERTY
TAX INCREMENT GOES AND SO WE
WILL PLEDGE TO CONTINUE WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR.
FIGURE OUT IF THERE ISN'T AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO.
MEET BOTH OBJECTIVES THINK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WE ACTUALLY
ALTHOUGH PART OF THE COALITION
YOU JUST HEARD FROM. OUR
POSITION AS OPPOSED LASSEN
MANDATE WE SHARE THE EXACT SAME
CONCERNS OF THE COALITION
RELATING TO THE. ISSUE OF THE
PASSED THE LANGUAGE WERE
RELATIVE TO THE PASSED THROUGH
AGREEMENT.
THE LACK OF.
REQUIRING CONCURRENCE OF THE
OTHER TAXI
HE'S.
BUT WE IN FACT HAVE A MEETING
SCHEDULED.
LATER THIS WEEK TO
TO GO OVER OUR SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WITH. MISTER CHIU STAFF AND WE
HOPE WE CAN REACH SOME
UNDERSTANDING.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE PATTERNS COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MR TRUCK.
THIS IS A VERY INTERESTING.
.
A CONCEPT I I UNDERSTAND THE OUR
OFFICE INTENT OF TO.
.
HAVE.
THERE ARE REVENUE STREAM FOR
AFFORDABLE HOMES SO FROM.
TRADITIONAL TWENTY PERCENT TO
THIRTY PERCENT.
ESSENTIALLY REVIVING NOW OR THE
ID A.
IN KNOW WHICH FROM THE
BEGINNING.
YOUR WAS.
OF SUCH A SUCH A.
THE IN OUR BIG CHAOS ARE.
AND THAT DISRUPTED DUH. OUR
WERE.
ORANGE COUNTY YEAH. OUR GREAT
PAUL. WHICH WHY CELLPHONE GOING.
UNDER THE R. D. A IT WAS SO.
A BIG PROBLEM. NOW EVEN BEFORE
THAT TEST IT IS SO SAD OWN NOW
WE ARE TRYING TO.
.
IT.
IT WILL BE IS ACTUALLY ON THE
DIFFERENT NAME ARE ASIA I A
NOTCH ON TO REALLY. REVIVED THE
HAWORTHIA A LITTLE MORE NOW
ALLOCATION.
.
OF THE AFFORDABLE NOW HOME.
SHARE.
I WONDER IF WHILE WE.
PASS THAT IS SO.
THEY'RE ALL THE PROBLEMS SO THAT
WAS STATED. NOT WHEN THE IDA
WAS.
.
ELIMINATED AND.
THIS CELL CURRENT.
GOVERNOR.
WHETHER HE WOULD BUY INTO YOU
IDEA AGAIN HE'S STILL A MAIN
MAIN NORTH OUT TO US.
A ELIMINATE THAT THE ITA.
WE THINK ABOUT THAT.
SO WHAT A COUPLE OF THOUGHTS AND
AND COLLEAGUES FIRST OF ALL LET
ME JUST THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING
WITH US ON THIS SIGNIFICANT
TOPIC. I'VE HEARD FROM VIRTUALLY
EVERY MEMBER THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE SPOKEN ON THIS TOPIC THAT.
OF FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO BRING
SOME VERSION OF THE TOOL BACK IN
THEIR BEEN ATTEMPTS
SINCE REDEVELOPMENT WAS.
ELIMINATED WITH CREE ISN'T HE
AYE IF DIS AN AJ'S AND NIFTY IS
TO BRING SOMETHING BACK BUT NONE
OF THEM HAVE WORKED IN AND A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE HAD A
HEARING IN THIS COMMITTEE. ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES WITH THE TOOLS
THAT HAVE BEEN CRAFTED SO FAR SO
THIS IS REALLY AN ATTEMPT TO TO
TAKE A A SIGNIFICANT STEP
FORWARD IN THIS AREA BUT I WILL
MENTION. COMPARED TO OLD
REDEVELOPMENT IN JUST TO PUT
THIS AND.
AND SCALE NAM AT THE TIME
REDEVELOPMENT WAS ELIMINATED.
THERE ABOUT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS YEAR THAT WERE SPENT ON
A REDEVELOPMENT AND TWENTY
PERCENT OF THAT WAS TO GO TO
HOUSING.
WE ARE PROPOSING REALLY JUST
FOCUSING ON THAT HOUSING PORTION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE SO UP WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE SPENDING THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE USED
TO SPEND ON. AS I REFERRED TO
BEFORE IN SOME INSTANCES GOLF
COURSES AND STRIP MALLS AND
OTHER SORTS OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
THAT THERE WERE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT. I ALSO WANT TO
REITERATE THAT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT SAFEGUARDS AND THIS
BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE ISSUES
IN THE PAST SO. ROBUST ANTI
DISPLACEMENT POLICIES DETAILED
RECORD KEEPING REQUIREMENTS
INDEPENDENT AUDITS HARSH
FINANCIAL PENALTIES AND FINES
FOR VIOLATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN. IN ADDITION TO
THAT YOU ALLUDED TO THE GOVERNOR
THE GOVERNOR UNDERSTANDABLY SOME
YEARS BEFORE I THINK ANY OF US
GOT HERE TO THE LEGISLATURE. WAS
FACING A VERY SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
CRISIS
AND HE.
OPPOSED AND IT WAS ACCEPTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE THAT THE WAY TO
BALANCE IT WAS TO ADDRESS THE
THE FISCAL POLL OF THE RESOURCES
THAT HAD BEEN AND REDEVELOPMENT.
WHAT WE DO WITH THIS BILL? IS WE
WE ALLOW THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT ARM
AND A PARTICULAR GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE FINAL
DECISION ON WHETHER OR NOT. ANY
PARTICULAR DISTRICT WOULD MOVE
FORWARD AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME OBJECTION ABOUT
WHETHER THAT IS APPROPRIATE BUT
WE THINK PARTICULAR WITH THIS
GOVERNOR. ARE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE FISCAL.
ISSUES THAT WOULD FACE THIS
GOVERNOR OR ANY FUTURE GOVERNOR.
TOM I WOULD ALSO SAY A THAT. WE
KNOW THAT THIS GOVERNOR HAS HAS
BEEN OPPOSED TO BRING HIM BACK
DIFFERENT VERSIONS
REDEVELOPMENT.
WE ARE HOPING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE COMING
MONTHS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THEY
MAY HAVE BUT I WILL ALSO SAY.
THAT MAJOR GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATES WHO ARE OF OF WHICH
ONE IS EXPECTED TO TAKE OFFICE
OUT EARLY NEXT YEAR HAVE ALL
SAID THAT THEY WANT TO BRING
BACK A SIGNIFICANT VERSION OF
REDEVELOPMENT SO WE ARE TRYING
TO DO. EARLY WORK RIGHT NOW TO
IRON OUT THE KINKS OF ANY POLICY
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE. BLESSING ON US AND I WON
ADDRESS.
.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED BY SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE WORKED HARD
IN RECENT MONTHS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS. UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION WE ARE REQUIRED TO
INCLUDE ALL TAX ALL TAXING
ENTITIES THAT RECEIVE PROPERTY
TAXES
SO THAT INCLUDES CITIES COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
TO PARTICIPATE BUT ARE BILL IS
DRAFTED TO MAKE COUNTIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS HOLE THROUGH
PASSED THROUGH PAYMENTS AND I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME ISSUES
AROUND. EXACTLY HOW THAT'S
DRAFTED AND A I AM COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THOSE CONCERNS AND
LOOK FORWARD. TO HOPEFULLY DOING
THAT IN SHORT ORDER AND THEN.
AS I MENTIONED FOR THE FUNDS
THAT WERE DIVERTED FROM SCHOOLS
WOULD BE BACK FILLED UNDER PROP
NINETY EIGHT SO THIS IS REALLY
AGAIN ABOUT GIVING CITIES.
LIKE YOU'RE SITTING IN IRVINE
THAT THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED.
TO ADDRESS AGAIN THE WORST
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN OUR STATE HISTORY
AS WELL AS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF THAT WE
HAVE AS WELL.
IN ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER WHAT.
AS WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD.
AS AS A FORMER A LOCAL ELECTED
WHO WENT THROUGH.
THE READ DEVELOPMENT.
DISMANTLING.
IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR CITIES IN
THE LAST MAJOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECT WAS BUILT.
ONLY THROUGH REDEVELOPMENT AND
AS A ABSOLUTE CRITICAL TOOL FOR
A COMMUNITY WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
CENTS SO SO I APPLAUD YOU THAT
WITH FOR THAT AND I AYE. AYE.
AYE AND I KNOW YOU DON'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE CHALLENGES OF
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
BECAUSE I THINK ANY ANY EFFORTS
TO DO ANYTHING RELATED TO
REDEVELOPMENT HAVE BEEN.
STRONGLY PUSHED BACK ON BUT I I
APPRECIATE THAT'S COMPLETELY
SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
ALSO.
ALSO DO THAT WITH SOME
TREPIDATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WHO WAS A HUGE THORN
IN OUR SIDE.
AND AS HAS REDEVELOPMENT WAS
DISMANTLED REMATCH EVERYTHING WE
ASK FOR IS A CITY WAS MET WITH
THE WORD NO.
AND CONSISTENTLY AND WE HAD TO
FIGHT AND FIGHT AND FIGHT FOR
ANYTHING SO SO I. HOPE THAT. IT
WHILE WE'RE GIVING POTENTIALLY
GIVING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
CONTROL TO
APARTMENT OF FINANCE I HOPE THAT
THERE ARE SOME GUARDRAILS THERE.
OUGHT TO PROTECT A CITIES OF WHO
HAVE REALLY GOOD STRONG PROJECTS
THERE SO THEY WENT THANK YOU AND
I LOOK FOR DISCORDANT BUT. I
THINK THEY MISSED WHAT WAS YOUR
JOB. TAKE YOU VERY MUCH.
I ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
THE CHAIR FOR CARRYING THIS BILL
I REMEMBER THAT UNDER THE OLD OF
SYSTEM THE OAT RD A ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT BEING DATA. ON YOU
KNOW FUNDS IS THAT THEY ARE WHO
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE USED FOR
EDUCATION WERE BEING ARE.
MR A DATA OR SORTS SUIT SO UNDER
YOUR BILL ARE YOU MISSION THAT
THAT THE ABOUT NINETY EIGHT
FUNDS GOING TO BE BACK FEEL TO
IT THAT. ESSENTIALLY FIX WHAT WE
HAD ENCOUNTERED IT IN THAT THE
BUT THAT WE SPACE THAT'S RIGHT
THE MONEY WOULD HE PULL THROUGH
THIS BUT BUT PROP NINETY EIGHT
WOULD TAKE CARE OF IT SO THE
SCHOOLS WHAT HAVE HOPEFULLY
BETTER. CORRECTIONAL YES.
I GOT THINGS.
MITT MISSING THE MARK.
THANK YOU AND I WANNA THANK YOU
ALSO FOR RAISING THIS
CONVERSATION I ACTUALLY WAS PART
OF OF THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY THAT
HAD REAL CONCERNS WITH
REDEVELOPMENT. AND NOT BECAUSE
IT DID HAVE MERITS BUT BECAUSE
YOU WOULD SEE EXAMPLES OF.
ISSUES WHERE IT'S JUST IT WAS
TAKEN AWAY FROM. YOU KNOW ONE
POT TO GO INTO SOMETHING THAT
JUST DIDN'T SETTLE WELL I THINK
IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES. BUT.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE IT'S ALSO THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY THAT IS LOOKING FOR
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES IN
COMMUNITIES FOR FOR THE
REDEVELOPMENT.
SO I'M GLAD THAT IT'S COMING TO
S. IN A NINETY YEAR CONCEPT
THAT'S VERY FOCUS THAT MUCH MORE
NARROW. AND SO THAT IT CAN ALLOW
SOME OF US HAVE WHO HAVE HAD
CONCERNS.
WITH THE USE OF SOME OF THIS IN
THE PAST
TO REALLY HAVE COME ON BOARD SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL HAPPEN.
I KNOW THAT THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY WILL BE INVOLVED BUT I
THINK THAT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES ALL AROUND
AND IT'S A MISSING PIECE. OF
WHERE RAT NOW AND PART OF THIS
LARGER EQUATION OF HOW WE GET
TO.
SOLVE SOME OF OUR HOUSING
COMPLICATIONS.
A IN. MYSTERY HITS ACOSTA.
THANK YOU CHAIR I. WOULD LIKE TO
ASK.
ONLY ONE MAJOR.
.
PROBLEMATIC GUY ISSUE IS.
THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES HAVE
pNOT CREATE THAT WE DEVELOP ONE
ARE.
AGENCY.
WITHOUT THOSE VOTER APPROVAL.
CAN YOU ELIMINATE THAT THAT THE
LEFT ON LOCAL PEOPLE OR TWO.
DECIDE THIS IS SOME MAJOR
ISSUES SO.
THAT'S THE ONLY AREA THAT DOES.
IN ROME.
DONNA LET THE LOCAL LAWS
CITIZENS TO GET INVOLVED. IF
THAT THE.
IF THAT THAT IS SO GREEDY OF
AFFORD TO SUIT THAT DUNLOP
BELIEVES.
THAT'S HOW IT WAS STRUCTURED
UNDER A THAT HAS THAT UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION THAT IS HOW IT'S
STRUCTURED.
HOW REDEVELOPMENT?
WAS FORMED FOR AGAIN WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IS WE ARE LIMITING
WHAT THE USES COULD BE. WITH
SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH SIGNIFICANT
SAFEGUARDS AND GUARD RAILS ARE
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS FOCUSED
ON.
ON ON CRITICAL HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS WITH ALL OF
THE LEVELS OF PURPLE APPROVALS
THAT I DESCRIBED BEFORE.
BUT THE QUICK ANSWER QUESTIONS
THAT IS HOW IT'S STRUCTURED
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION THE STATE
CONSTITUTION.
SO IT UNDER THE STATE
CONSTITUTION ALLOWS
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES DO NOT
REQUIRE A VOTE OF A LOCAL
JURISDICTION BUT WHAT WE'RE
SAYING WITH THIS LAW IS YOU HAVE
TO. AGAIN GET THE APPROVALS THAT
WE DISCUSSED WITH THE SAFEGUARDS
THAT WE DISCUSSED AS WELL.
THANK.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS.
AND FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS I.
FIND MYSELF.
IN.
.
AGREEMENT WITH NUMBER THE
WITNESSES WHO ARE KIND OF
SUPPORTIVE AND CONCEPT.
I'MI THINK IT ILLUSTRATES THE
THE HUGE GAP.
THAT OCCURRED AS A LOSS OF
REDEVELOPMENT.
AND YOU KNOW.
S. SOMEBODY IN WHEN I TOOK. AS
ME WHO WORKS A LOT IN THIS AREA
WHEN I TOOK OFFICE ON THE CITY
THE CITY COUNCIL OUR DOWNTOWN
WAS JUST UNSAFE IT WAS
UNPRODUCTIVE ME WAS A MASS YOU
CAN WALK AROUND AT NIGHT. I'M
AND NOW YOU KNOW ALL I HEAR YOU
KNOW APPEAR AS WE LOVE YOUR CITY
IT'S WONDERFUL TO COME DOWN AND
VISIT WE YOUR DOUBT YOUR GASLAMP
AREAS GREAT WE BUILT A BALLPARK
WE. REDEVELOPMENT ALL THAT WE IT
WASN'T JUST.
ECHO PARK WHICH WAS
INDUCES FOURTEEN AREAS FOURTEEN
BLOCKS
I IN AROUND THERE THAT WE
REDEVELOP AT BRIAN RESTAURANTS
BARS AND. LOT OF INCOME
PRODUCING.
REVENUE LOT OF JOBS INCOME
PRODUCING REVENUE FOR THAT.
.
FOR THE CITY AS WELL AND SUCH A
HUGE LOSS IT'S A HUGE LOSS TO
WHAT WE DID ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING YOU JUST WHAT WE GET FOR
THE HOMELESS.
INTO MY COLLEAGUE MS AT AT THE
TIME AND I GET THE IS STILL TO
MISS ATKINS AND I. KNOW WE
REALLY CHAMPION LET'S GET MORE
DONE ON A FOUR HOUSING WAS TOO
MORE FOR HOMELESS WE'RE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
THROUGH THE REDEVELOPMENT AND
IS PROTECTED FRUSTRATING TO SEE
A NOTE THERE BUT THERE WERE
RAISING OF PEOPLE EXPRESSED
CONCERN ABOUT WILL THERE BE
FURTHER RAIDS ON THESE
REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS.
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE WITH COME TO
THIS SORT OF COMPELLED
PARTICIPATION AS I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LACK OF VOTER
APPROVAL.
ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK AGAIN I
JUST GO WITH MY EXPERIENCE WHAT
REALLY HELPED US ON
REDEVELOPMENTS WE HAD SUCH BY
IAN.
I IN WE HAD THAT WE DEFER HAD.
THE NAY SAYERS AND THAT AND THE
PEOPLE WHO GOT A LOT OF MEDIA
ATTENTION BUT BY AND LARGE
PEOPLE WERE. WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
INTERESTINGLY NOW THAT WE HAVE
THE BALLPARK AND ALL THAT
EVERYBODY OF COURSE A SPORT OF
BUT.
.
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT
THAT DOWN IN THAT IN THAT WAY
I'M. ALSO A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE CHEFS IN
MONEY.
THAT MAY GO AWAY FROM AYE AYE
INTO WHETHER IT'S LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIREFIGHTERS.
SOME OF THE OTHER PUBLIC
SERVICE I THINK THAT CHYNA NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY.
I I APPLAUD WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND I AND I THINK IT'S.
IT'S TOO BAD WE'RE COMEY PUT IN
THIS POSITION IN SOME SENSE OF
WERE TRYING TO FIND BECAUSE
REDEVELOPMENT GONE IN AND AN
OVERALL REDEVELOPMENT DID SO
MUCH GOOD THERE. SURLY THERE
WERE INSTANCES WHERE IS ABUSE
BUT THOSE SHOULD OF BEEN
ADDRESSED NOW IT'S TRYING TO
FIND A SOLUTION.
.
YOU A CAB MORE MORE PIECEMEAL
SO.
.
I AYE I WON'T SUPPORT IT TODAY
OUT I WILL CONTINUE TO IN I'LL
OFFER. YOU KNOW TO TO WORK WITH
YOU GOING FORWARD ON THIS I KNOW
YOUR. PASSIONS ARE AND I THINK
YOUR HEAT FOR MAKING SOME SOME
PROGRESS I JUST CAN'T QUITE GET
THERE.
TODAY SO WITH THAT AND WE HAVE
A MOTION.
MOTION FOR MR CHOW SECOND FROM
MISTER WHAT MISTER CHAIR REJECT
CLOSE SHIRT LET ME JUST CLOSE
WITH TWO POINTS A AYE AYE HERE
FROM OUR COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
AISLE THAT ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS A
LACK OF VOTER APPROVAL. WERE NOT
INCREASING.
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
FUNDS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO
YOUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHERE
THEY CAN BE USED.
BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
RAISING PROPERTY TAXES WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
THE FLOWS OF FUNDS COMING BACK
IN AND WHERE THEY SHOULD BE USED
WHERE THEY SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED.
I THINK GIVEN THE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE GIVEN THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THAT WE HAVE
THE HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK IN SAN
DIEGO THE ENCAMPMENTS THAT WERE
SEEN IN ORANGE COUNTY. OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WERE SEEN AND.
AS THE MONTHS DISTRICT AND
DOCTOR WHICH DISTRICT GIVEN THE
FIRES AND MUD SLIDES WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN CITIES LIKE MINE AND
AND AND EVERY CITY IN THE IN THE
STATE. OF THIS CRISIS WAS CAUSED
IN PART BECAUSE OF THE
REDEVELOPED THAT THE ELIMINATION
OF REDEVELOPMENT AND THE LOSS OF
A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FUNDING.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS TO TO BRING THAT BACK.
BUT DO IT WITH THE APPROPRIATE
LEVELS OF OF CONTROL AND AND
OVERSIGHT ARE AS WELL AS WITH
WITH BY AND FROM LOCALITIES. IN
A WAY THAT THAT HOLDS A HARMLESS
A AND INSURES THAT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IN FAR DISTRICTS IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE MADE WHOLE.
SO THAT IS THE INTENT OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THIS IS
COMPLICATED AYE IT IS GOING TO
BE A LONGER TERM CONVERSATION.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU I DO HOPE WE
CAN RESOLVE IT THIS YEAR BUT IT
IS NOT RESOLVED THIS YEAR IT
WILL CERTAINLY?
BE ISSUE WE'RE GOING TO BE
TACKLING AND AND AND STRONG
FORCE EARLY NEXT YEAR WITH
WHOEVER THE NEXT GOVERNOR AT SO
MY HOPE IS A WHAT I WOULD ASK. A
ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES IS TO
CONTINUE TO GIVE US INPUT AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS I DO HOPE TO
HAVE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS AS WE
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WELL IF YOU HAVE ONE WHAT KIND
OF RAT.
WAS.
VOTING NOW DIY FOR AT RISK. YEAH
I'M IN IMPORTANT BETWEEN US MUCH
US OUT IN A PERSON WE HAD A VERY
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE SAID AND I'D
LOVE TO SUPPORT HIS ABOUT THEIR.
AT THAT TIME IF THE SO DYSPHORIA
OF IP IT.
WHEN YOU ARE A DEVELOPED BY A
OUT OF REDEVELOPMENT PLAN THAT
THE CITY OUT WALK COUNTY IT
WOULD IT WOULD HAVE A PLAN HOW
YOU WHEN I. READ DEVELOPER INDIA
SO YOU WOULD HAVE ARE YOU KNOW
MASTER PLAN AND THE OWNERS.
WHAT DID THE CITIZENS SO WHO IS
THE LEADING IN THAT AREA SHOULD
HAVE A FOR A SAFE TO SOMEONE THE
FOR?
OUR PLAN COMING THERE WERE BY
INTO IT. SO PATRICIA WE ACTUALLY
WE THAT THE THE BILL DOESN'T
VISION THAT THE AGENCY HAS TO
PROVIDE A PLAN OF THE MONIES CAN
BE USED FOR.
IS OTHER IN THEIR LIFE AND JUST
WELCOME AT THE GENERAL PLAN KNOW
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CONSTITUTION
NOR DOES NOT ALLOW THAT THE I
DON'T KNOW QUITE UNDERSTAND SO
INVESTED THE PHOTO INVOLVEMENT
DESIST ABOUT THAT.
IT IN AWE HOW HOW IT THE TAX
INCREMENT THE NOT TAX SOME MONEY
WOULD BE USED OF SO. THOSE OF
CITIZENS ARE LIVING INSIDE
SHOULD HAVE SOME VOICE SO LET ME
IT THIS IS THIS IS SIMILAR TO
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE CITY COUNCIL.
AND YOU MADE DECISIONS WITH YOUR
CITY COUNCIL HAVE YOUR GENERAL
FUND WAS USED YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GO BACK TO VOTERS.
FOR A VOTE OUT EXACTLY HOW MUCH
MONEY YOU SPENT ON POLICE AND
FIRE AND.
SOCIAL SERVICES AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
YOU WERE ENTRUSTED WITH THAT
VOTE AND THAT'S HOW THE
STRUCTURE OR NOT INCREASING
TAXES THIS IS A WAY FOR. A THESE
JURISDICTIONS TO DECIDE HOW
MONIES THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
FLOWING TO THE JURISDICTION
WOULD BE USED AND.
PART OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE
IS WE WANT TO GIVE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ABILITY TO CREATE
A STRUCTURE. TO MOVE SOME OF
THIS FUNDING TOWARD HOUSING AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
ALL DEFINED IN THE IN THE BILL.
SO THAT CITIES LIKE IRVINE I
CAN HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
RELIEF WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE TODAY THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT. FORMOSA
CITIZENS INVOLVED THE WITHIN
THAT.
REDUCED THAT THE RETIREMENT
AREA HAD THE VOICE THAT THE
BOARD ON IT THEY WOULD HAVE A
VOICE THROUGH THE PUBLIC
PROCESS.
THAT THE AGENCY WOULD SET UP.
SO SHORT OF A VOTE IT'S NOT AN
ACTUAL WOULD ATTACH A PHOTO
APPROVAL OF FATTY SAYS SOMETHING
IN OUR BUT IT BOTHERS ME.
I AGAIN I APPRECIATE WHAT IT
WHAT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
INCREASING TAXES.
WORK WILL TALK ABOUT THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS IN THE WAY
THAT A CITY COUNCIL WOULD WOULD
DECIDE HOW TO USE.
GENERAL FUNDS.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO PASS TO
LOCAL GRAVEL AND THAT SECOND
ESCORT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MAIENSCHEIN. NO MAIENSCHEIN NO
CHAU.
SHALL I.
CHOI.
RELUCTANTLY KNOWN.
SHOWING NO GLORIA.
LIMON.
THREE MONTH I WOULD.
WOULD I.
CHIU. AYE TO AYE.
THIS.
RUSSIA PASSWORD TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP BEFORE
ANYONE LEAVES I HAVE OF AND
BEFORE WE DO ADD ON VOTES I JUST
HAVE ONE FINAL ANNOUNCEMENT.
TODAY IS THE LAST DAY.
FOR THE LAST COMMITTEE HEARING
FOR AN INCREDIBLE STAFFER OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
REBEKAH ABOUT SKI HAS BEEN WITH
US FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS SHE
HAS HELPED US TO SHEPHERD.
HOW WAS BILLS TO THE PROCESS
AROUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
PROTECT TENANTS?
LAST YEAR DURING THE HISTORIC
HOUSING PACKAGE THAT WE PASSED
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL TO THAT.
SHE'S BEEN IN PUBLIC SERVICE
OUR WHOLE LIFE AND UNFORTUNATELY
FOR US SHE'S GOING OVER TO THE
SENATE BUT SHE WILL NOT BE FAR.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
OF FROM FOR MY TEAM FROM OUR
HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFF FROM
THE.
HOUSING COMMUNITY STATEWIDE.
YOU'VE BEEN INCREDIBLE YOU'VE
BEEN.
JUST AN AMAZING ASSET TO TO US
AND WE'RE GONNA MISS YOU BUT TO
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
YOUR NEW CAPACITY AND SENATE.
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF.
ITEMS THAT ARE STILL ON CALL
MAYBE IT SHOULD JUST TAKE IT
FROM THE TOP.
OKAY.
IT'S LIKE WE.
RIGHT NOW WE JUST THAT'S FOR
STUDENTS.
OKAY SO OUR ITEM ONE STEINORTH.
IT WILL NOT BE MOVING FORWARD.
ITEM TO.
CHLOE I CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
YEAH CHAO.
THE OPPOSITE.
IBM AB AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE
BLOOM. TELL AYE AYE.
SHALL I.
CHOI.
JOEY NO.
LEE MON. REMOTE I.
WOULD. WOULD I.
.
LINE ITEM THREE AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN IS AREA.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO HIGH SHELF
I.
AND. THAT IS.
FIVE TO TWO.
SUCH TO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FOR A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE BONTA.
MEMBER WOULD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHICH I THAT THE
BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. BUT
BILLS OUT OF FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO WERE
THERE ANY ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBER OKAY A FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT KANSEN
CHU.
FROM MY FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THURMAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO HIGH. SOME
OF WHICH ARE SHALL I SEVEN TWO
ZERO. THE BILL'S OUT AND FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN BLOOM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHALL I.
I ASSEMBLY WHICH I THOUGHT HE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
I I.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOEY I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND.
I.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOOD.
THE PILLS OUT AS WELL.
ZERO.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN SO THAT THERE CAN BE ONE
FINAL AND ON BUT OTHERWISE THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE
.
YEAH.
THE GOAL
WE WILL.
TO A COUPLE I THINK IF ONE OR
TWO FINAL ADD ONS.
MISTER GLORIA WE'RE GOING TO
RECALL FILE ITEM NINE EIGHTY
THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS MY
ITEM AROUND REDEVELOPMENT.
MADAM SECRETARY.
ASSEMBLY OF A GLORIA. AYE. OKAY
THAT ITEM.
PASSES BY TO TO.
AND WITH THAT AT THIS TIME WE
ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU REBEKAH